Kai Lopez is one of the most prolific
marketers of the 2010s Gathering
billions of views making hundreds of
millions of dollars maybe it's made
almost 100 Mil and it all started in his
garage with his new Lamborghini here in
the Hollywood Hills here in my garage
just bought this uh new Lamborghini here
it's fun to drive up here in the
Hollywood Hills although out of nowhere
taion was completely disappeared from
social media and he's been relatively
quiet online until now we got the
opportunity to confront him in person
discuss his experiences selling programs
online and get a glimpse into the life
of someone who's built a marketing
Empire from nothing but knowledge
knowledge hearing from other people is
one of the best ways to educate
ourselves on viewpoints we might not
always agree with we'd like to allow a
place where everyone is able to talk
freely with the mindset that you might
learn something new so with that said
guys thank you so much and before we go
into it a quick message from our sponsor
YouTube is filled with some of the best
high quality content on the internet and
for any Creator who's looking to grow
their brand YouTube is one of the best
resources but when you spend countless
hours making content about knowledge
that it took you years to develop
sometimes posting it for free can feel
demotivating well thankfully today's
sponsor you screen is the perfect
solution you screen is an easy to use
video membership platform that allows
creators with large or small followings
to get paid the way they want to they
have everything in one place and handle
all the video hosting live streaming
payments billing marketing and more it
even allows you to build your own fully
branded mobile and TV apps like Apple TV
Roku Fire TV and of course IOS and
Android apps that way your members could
access your content anywhere at any time
ustcreen gives you access to powerful
website themes designed to monetize
videos it's fully customizable and you
can set it up yourself with no coding
experience required it's perfect for
video creators instructors coaches
authors influencers and entrepreneurs
looking to build a predictable Revenue
stream with their video content u-screen
is the video membership site for
professional content creators looking to
generate a sustainable income so if
you're interested in use screen feel
free to check them out down below in the
description it helps support the podcast
and that way they know that we sent you
enjoy thank you guys with that said and
back to the podcast here on the ice
coffee hour time for a little knowledge
let's go
thank you so much for coming on thanks
for having me I want you to the iced
coffee hour I'm so curious that's a good
question I've been off social media for
I mean I haven't been doing much so
I've decided I'm gonna go back into the
social media world so I was like this is
a good place to start this is cool we
appreciate about the speaking of going
back Jack I haven't told you this in
2009 I showed you and Maya houses in
Beverly Hills I bet you don't remember
huh I think I vaguely do you reached out
to me from a posting I did on Craigslist
okay it was this house in Doheny I think
it was like 9 000 a month okay I met you
there you hated the house okay I sent
you other lists why did I hate the house
it wasn't a good house you wouldn't have
liked it why'd you take me there well I
gotta I gotta meet you
let's meet this dude I had these houses
that were on Craigslist that were priced
really well that had a decent amount of
like bedrooms bathrooms to the pool but
when people walk in they just don't like
the house for whatever reason so it's a
good house to meet people at right uh no
one really liked the house but I'd meet
them there and then show them other
houses that that seller was like I
understand we got a lot of showing but
nobody ever buys we read eventually
rented the house but like when you go in
there it's kind of dark it's a little
it's not everyone's style yeah you know
but anyway should you and Maya I think
you eventually rented something else
like I was up in Hollywood Hills right
around then yeah 2009 yeah but it's
funny I had recognized when I met you in
person from the millionaire matchmakers
yeah okay yeah no so you're like you
know me like old school yeah this is
before this is before everything before
it yeah I wasn't yeah I think I was
looking back I joined Twitter like in
0809 that was my beginning I remember
being like I'm gonna mess with this
social media thing didn't do YouTube
insta wasn't a thing I was like what
were you doing before then because when
I spoke with Maya she was saying you did
some tall Productions or there there's
promotion yeah so I had so
I had a company on the East Coast my
first one of my first businesses was a
big nightclub nightlife company in North
Carolina I partnered with this guy who
owned all these restaurants I ran the
nightlife so I had this promotions
company I still have it and it is so
yeah that's kind of the old days that's
got me I always tell people the way to
start it's like at the beginning there's
a progression to making money and I know
people a lot of people say you shouldn't
sell your time for money but it's not
realistic and it actually at the
beginning you do sell your time for
money I mean Bill Gates started as a
teenager he was selling his time for
money rebuilding the payroll system for
his school you know Elon Musk was doing
that kind of everybody hustles at the
beginning doing that kind of thing and
then over time hopefully you grow out of
that phase but I was still a little bit
in that phase probably when I met you
yeah where did you start where you
started on a farm yeah on a farm man old
school I um out of high school I I
didn't have enough quite enough money to
go to school I had some scholarships to
colleges but this guy Joel saliton who's
now a Fame he's become pretty famous
he's like the most famous farmer organic
kind of farmer and he had a he had an
apprenticeship open and I was like okay
so I went and lived on a farm for 18
months no toilet he had a little cabin
he cut a hole in the floor and put a
bucket under there he's like every once
in a while you're gonna have to empty
that in the forest so I did that for
yeah I did Manual Labor for a couple
years but the second year I was with him
there was a farmer that came to Joel and
said I don't know what to do with my
land and Joel said I'm too busy and just
turned the guy down I don't know even
with the guy and I went to Joel that I
was a teenager and I said Joel I'll work
for you all day in that night I'll go
take care of that farm if you we split
the money we do a business together so
he bought a whole bunch of cattle I
didn't have any money first time using
other people's money he bought like
fifty thousand dollars worth of cattle I
took care of him I used to put a little
I would work at his farm from like five
in the morning to five at night and then
I would put this like headlamp was
before where people really had headlamps
I like built it into like a little
flashlight rubber band in my head we'll
go take care of this Farm did that for
like eight months and I made twelve
thousand dollars in a year I mean that
was the most money I'd ever seen I grew
I graduated high school in a mobile home
you know so I was like 12 Grand was a
lot and so that was the first business
then I came back to the city then I
lived with the Amish for two and a half
years
so that was no electricity in the city
no before the city so after Joel then I
did two and a half so I was gone from
like the regular world for almost five
years four or five years then I came
back to the city and how'd you get
linked up with the Amish what made you
choose that and I was at Joel Joel's
Farm was famous people come from all
over the world I'd meet people I met the
prime minister of like Russia came it
was all this but the Amish used to come
there and I was fascinated I didn't have
a very happy childhood and the Amish are
like super happy people
and so I guess I was fighting my demons
and I was like I wonder what it'd be
like to go live with people that were
peaceful you know and I so I lived with
Amish it was a very cathartic experience
I guess you would say because like I
growing up like I didn't know families
didn't yell at each other I didn't know
any of that like then I went to the
Amish I'm like wow there are actual
peaceful
marriages and my dad was married
multiple times so it was my mom I grew
up with a stepdad so and a simple mom so
it was probably I sometimes wonder what
would have happened if I hadn't gone to
the Amish
I think it would have been a better
businessman been more ruthless so you're
with the Amish for two and a half years
you said yeah I was there a long time
find like a foster home yeah it's hard
and you just helped them out Charlie I
heard they don't let like Outsiders in
huh they don't really but I knew about
farming and so there were a lot of
farmers and they knew Joel salatin so
they're like it was kind of like maybe
this guy will
show me what Joel taught him I remember
first Amish farm I went to was Lancaster
Pennsylvania it was insane I I took a
bus there because I didn't have any
money I didn't have a car took a bus
there and I got out and was like going
back to the 1700s I walked into this
barn and there was a guy like shoveling
Apple pumice it's like the peelings of
apple and he had little kids and they
were all wearing like hats and then we
worked there and then I went in the
house like here's a room and the first
thing you do in like a room is to flip
the light switch but they don't have
electricity there's no light switches so
you're like and you gotta go light a
candle and I got little lanterns it was
good man you slay it was it's a great
life in fact
I interviewed there's a guy Jared
Diamond he wrote a famous book Guns
Germs deal I was interviewing him a
couple years ago and he's like oh you
know the Amish she goes you know I
studied the Amish they have 500 percent
less depression than the mainstream
Community he was very fascinated and I
was like it's true he's the happiest
people I've ever met so I think that um
you know the modern world is there's
this Sigmund Freud the founder of modern
psychology he said civilization in his
discontents like the social structure
that we live in
basically we live longer because we're
in a modern civilization but we're less
happy we're not as connected to Nature
or we're not connected to community you
know Amish group there's no divorce
everybody you're around your uncles and
your aunts and you're in part of a
bigger Community you marry people you
know people aren't like people are
lonely now man I mean the modern world
Fosters loneliness even for
entrepreneurs I I very rarely you know
I've kind of gone my life people don't
real I've gone from like one extreme
like the Amish and I've done the Beverly
Hills thing and you know making a lot of
money and basically what you want is
some of the best of the modern world but
I sometimes miss that a lot just like
the peace you know why did you decide to
leave because I mean ultimately I wasn't
Amish and they're they're their religion
and So eventually you kind of have to
stay and get married but sometimes I
wonder I wonder if my life's really
better that I left I mean certainly you
got more stuff now but um I think that
the old cliche that um money isn't
everything is true I I I kind of go by
this good life thing like life's the
four pillars of the good life like
health wealth love happiness and really
what your job is if you want a good life
is the ratio of those things those
pillars and that's very hard like the
greatest people in the world to me are
people who figure out those ratios
um I was just in Scandinavia I live
part-time in in Denmark now that you can
argue their ratios maybe are better than
here so like Sweden has five times the
billionaires per capita of America but
they're also way happier people you know
so that point I was like deep down the
happiness kind of pillar of the good
life living on a farm quiet good people
but I didn't know how to make money
really you know then I've gone all the
way to the other stream we're like
really good at making money but you're
missing out you know most entrepreneurs
it's like I knew an entrepreneur
he was worth a couple billion dollars
but he was so out of shape
bad Health diabetic the guy was
bedridden I remember thinking it's like
all the money in the nobody would trade
for that guy if I told you you can give
you two billion dollars in your bank
account but you can't get out of bed
you wouldn't trade right so I have this
thing now it's just my life I call it
the substitution rule so who do I envy
it's like Elon Musk because like I
respect Elon Musk but I don't envy him I
would I would I think the life that's
even he says it it's like very out of
the four pillar ratios or just your app
you know how you have this fish thing so
I do a lot I own a lot of Farmland now
and um just like that app for your fish
tank has the alkalinity ratio acid to
alkaline and yours is supposed to be 7.9
which is pretty alkaline like that's how
your life has to be like you have to
really get that it's easy to out outrace
your headlights
so P either people don't have enough
money and they have all this other stuff
maybe they have a nice family or they
got too much money and all the other
stuff's lost you know but first we got
to thank our sponsor kudas guys Graham
and I both have tons of credit cards and
with a lot of credit cards comes tons of
rewards and benefits but I know from
personal experience trying to maximize
the rewards and benefits from each one
of my unique credit cards is nearly
impossible yeah exactly for a while I
had over 10 credit cards and try to
figure out and remember which ones to
use where was extremely confusing but
thankfully our sponsor Kudos is there to
help Kudos is a free smart wallet that
guarantees you'll always get the most
rewards and benefits out of your credit
cards whenever you shop online no more
struggling to pick the right card just
shop like normal and at checkout Kudos
will show you the best credit card to
use to maximize your savings it's really
a no-brainer because the average user
unlocks 750 a year of extra value using
Kudos my favorite part of Kudos is that
they even look for hidden rewards like
travel insurance and purchase protection
benefits that you might not even know
you had like I was buying flights the
other day and Kudos reminded me that
checking out with the AmEx Platinum
would give me luggage Insurance
protection which is huge so to celebrate
for the holidays we're partnering with
Kudos who's going to be giving the first
1 000 people who sign up before December
25th a 10 Amazon gift card all you have
to do is click on the link Down Below in
our description and use code ich
underscore holiday and then check out
using the Kudos autofill feature and
you'll get the 10 Amazon gift card stop
throwing away free money and Shop
Smarter with Kudos with the link Down
Below in the description it is
completely free you get a 10 gift card
thank you so much Kudos and back to the
podcast what were some of the most
shocking Parts about moving in with the
Amish people was just like no technology
no cell phones or anything nope nope no
family fightings no that was no one shot
yeah because like I grew up like I
didn't really like my my dad was in
prison when I was born my mom was a
single mom you know she like peaceful
families I think I don't think a lot of
people have that like I never you can
ask an Amish kid like have you ever
heard your dad yell at your mom's like
never never I I lived I still know I own
Some Farms in the middle of that
community and there's still Amish people
who run them never heard an Amish guy
raise his voice are there any arguments
I mean there have to be some sort of
thing there are but it's just like I
mean actually now there's a scientist is
writing a book based on some of the
stuff that I talked about
um it's called why Amish babies don't
cry because Amish babies hardly cry it's
and so some of it now is actually
genetic there's a thing on a hexaco
score which is your the most modern
assessment of your personality it's like
25 sub-facets one of them is
agreeableness and so some people are
just naturally more agreeable and um
interestingly enough a lot of the
wealthiest people world are very low at
agreeableness and that's why
that's why there's this spectrums like
you can become a billionaire but you
might have to live a horrible life to
get there you know or you can can be
like Amish yeah so it's shocking it's
they're very agreeable people you know
do you ever get bored like not having no
you'll never get bored now okay I was on
a form of 900 horses man he's like horse
you have to like nature right so
video game I mean I was into video games
I don't know I I'm not a person that
gets bored that's not my I think it's
genetic to get bored oh I think boring
people get bored yeah boring but I also
think so going back to that hexaco thing
inquisitiveness is a genetic factor that
you have and so like some people you can
put them in the most fascinating
scenarios they're gonna get bored other
people you stick them in a room like
Joel Salton my first Mentor it was funny
you know he's this farmer guy and I had
him I had like all these Lambos and
stuff and I invited him to come speak at
my conference one of my first ones in
2014 or 24 and I remember thinking uh
his he's not a materialistic guys like
he's not gonna like that I have all this
so the only car I had was a Lamborghini
at the time so I picked him up at the
airport in the lambo and the black one
yeah I was a black one the little black
one I had and um he comes out and I
remember he walked her I had it parked
in the parking spot he like walks around
it three times and he's like
he noticed like a hundred things all the
Gearhead car people he noticed that
because he knows like farm tractors he's
like this is basically a chassis with a
little and I remember thinking
he's a high inquisitive person like Joel
never be bored you could stick him in a
room with just a car and he's gonna
dissect the whole thing so
I believe a lot of you know there's a
lot of genetic stuff about personality
that we don't realize affects us so I
have my weaknesses but getting bored
isn't wonderful and from those two and a
half years of your life that you spent
secluded and on this Amish farm what
would you say is the biggest takeaway or
the thing that I guess benefited you for
your career for your personal life or
something from then on you need a life
filled with a lot of people around you
um and that we're too isolated like
don't be isolated so live almost like
in a village type of living like when I
was even when I was doing all my social
media here in my garage like if you came
to my house there was probably 60 people
there at any time I like had my office
in there I had friends found people come
in be like what is this and I maybe it
was like my little version of like Amish
wow Amish living communities like 150
people there's people to be able to walk
around like not get alone time oh Graham
would yeah I hate it yeah yeah you would
be over it yeah but here's the thing so
introverts and extroverts is kind of
this concept you hear a lot about
um
that it was invented by this Carl Jung
this Swiss he invented actually the word
introvert expert
it's a myth how people think about it
introverts like to be around people they
trust and know so a lot of the stress is
with strangers right
so obviously there's some people who
don't even want to have five people they
know but I had people in my house I knew
that I wouldn't want 100 yeah 100
strangers rolling in and out of the
house that's
that's actually why people are unhappy
in cities like New York you go to New
York you gotta what you walk by 3 000
stranger or London everybody's in a bad
mood Jonathan height wrote this book and
your cortisol levels just automatically
go up you're like in fight or flight
mode you know you're like this person
might kill me subconsciously we are
humans we got this super primitive mind
you know so I think I I learned that
from the Amish is that Community is a
thing try build your tribe build your
tribe so what happened after you left
then I went like completely opposite I
came back I needed to make money and uh
that was when I was sleeping on my couch
for like 47. I had like skills I knew
how to like milk cows and harness horses
right so I'm I was back and um I had one
Uncle the only Uncle only person on our
family that ever made like six figures
except my dad my dad made six figures at
one point but selling cocaine so but
like legally my uncle was a car salesman
and I remember him telling me I was
sleeping on the couch and I was
depressed I had read this Tony Robbins
book awaken the giant within and yeah
yeah it's a great book he my mom gave it
to me because I was like depressed he's
like read this and we're thinking how's
this going to help me and the one
sentence was when you succeed you party
but when you fail you Ponder and all
greatness comes out of failure because
it makes you rethink your life so I was
like that's true so I I was smart enough
I had had mentors on the farm the
amish-like mentors too they don't they
they stop in eighth grade so you learn
from other people so I was like who's
the number one Mentor I knew that knew
how to make money in my world only
person was my Uncle Bill so I called him
I'm like Uncle Bill
I'm stuck I'm failing I'm pondering I
got no money or less than 50 bucks I'm
basically homeless in a mobile home he
goes two ways you can always make money
to I sell sell cars or sell insurance
and I was like I don't want to sell cars
because he had sold cars and he told me
it was a depressing life where you're at
like 16 hours a day at the so I went in
the phone book
and um
I knew that a phone book like to get the
full page thing was like fifty thousand
dollars I don't know how I knew that and
I just flipped through and I found first
Insurance person that had a full page ad
it was a guy named Mike stainback
and I go
I'm gonna call this guy so I called him
and I pretended like I needed insurance
I kind of did too so it wasn't a total
lie so I called I set up appointment at
the secretary Kathy and I showed up and
my uncle's like make sure you like wear
a suit I don't have a suit I went to a
thrift store I remember I wish I had a
picture of it I have it somewhere it had
shoulder pads it was the only one at the
thrift store it was like a woman's suit
it was like the office where I don't
know but it had shoulder pads so I
bought that thing was like six bucks but
but I showed up at that office I'm like
staying back and I was like Kathy and I
got my it was a blue pinstripe shoot uh
suit I think and I go in the back and
Mike had this big mustache and I was
like hey Mike I want to tell you I'm
interested in insurance I don't have a
lot of money but I know you got a full
page ad here so you must you're probably
the richest guy I've ever met and I said
if you will teach me what you know about
making money I'll work for you for free
and I remember he was just I don't know
he had this big mustache he looked like
a movie star guy and he was yeah Tom
said he was sitting on the side and he
like turned to me and he was like
I've been looking for someone like you
for 20 years there you go you got the
right attitude he goes show up in the
morning and I'll give you an office so I
was like well yeah so I left came back
the next day I'm expecting like an
office and he had taken a closet where
he had a file cabinet and he had stuffed
a little teeny uh place to put my
computer and I remember going in there
was so small if you I had a chair you
try to lean back you hit the wall it was
like it was probably I mean it was a
closet and I started cold calling that's
why I tell people if you study
billionaires wealthy people 80 of them
started in sales yep so that's how I
started so you started I hated cold
calling and door knocking it was my
least favorite but Craigslist worked
yeah but the thing is it's like it's
like Muhammad Ali said with sit-ups he
goes you know I don't count them until
they start to burn
but that's why he was the king like he
did sit-ups a lot people don't like to
do sit-ups so cold calling is like
sit-ups you don't like to do it but if
you do it it trains you so I in the
first week I opened a deal that was like
a hundred thousand of commissions and
Mike was in shock because he had
promised me like 30 of the commission
and I was like I'm gonna make 30 grand
and all this so I literally overnight I
started to make a little bit of money
like eight ten Grand a month which was
like Infinity
was it just like early 20s man I was
like really good money yeah yeah and and
what was crazy that so I started to
think
because he gave me this cold call list
but I called through it and then I was
done so I was I had I was on a laptop in
that little room and an ad came up it
was like a Yahoo ad I might have been I
don't think it was Google but it was a
picture of this dude
on a Hawaiian beach I remember and the
caption said how I made twenty eight
thousand dollars laying on the beach
today and I clicked it and it was an ad
for like a guru
and I remember it was probably in the
first week I hadn't actually received
any commissions so I had like three 400
breakout was 300 bucks to buy his system
his name is Corey rudel
sadly the guy died in 08 he had all
these Porsches and stuff and he crashed
oh man and uh I always thought about
when I made money and got all these cars
I'm like don't drive too fast man Corey
rule I always want to thank the dude
because I got a three ring binders
before YouTube for 300 bucks sent to me
and only thing I remember from it is
there's something new called Google ads
try it so I built an ad
advertising this Mike stainback's kind
of by then we were doing some Financial
stuff like annuities and mutual funds
and I put an ad up and instantly lead
started to pour in I got good at that
and I I ended up working at GE this
might guy from got me working as a
broker for G which at the time was the
biggest company in the world GA capital
and so I started like a click on on
Google ads at the beginning okay was
this 2004 yeah earlier either wow okay a
click on Google ads was roughly
20 cents okay and your convert I would
get a lead for like 15 bucks and I could
close one out of ten and my average
commission was 1500 bucks right now
those clicks are 20 bucks a piece
so that's why I always tell people find
the new platform get in early
and so I that really skyrocketed me and
um
that's when I started consistently
making six figures that's when I then
that guy that notebook also said have
multiple streams of income so I would
work in this finance company I spun out
my own with a business partner but doing
the same thing and I would work from
like 11 in the morning
maybe seven at night and then I would
take off and I had gotten this nightclub
business which was pretty big in North
Carolina it ended up being almost the
biggest nightlife company so then I
would do
seven at night till like three in the
morning the nightclub so I had these two
streams but it was fun like I was going
out it was like I owned some salsa
dancing clubs I own all this stuff it
was be you know I got in that business
because I went to a nightclub and it was
like 20 bucks for a drink and I was
thinking I'm on the wrong side of this
counter here I was like I know alcohol
cost a dollar or 50 cents
and so I go my second stream of income
is going to be nightlife I get paid to
have fun I think it started doing that
how long did it take between like okay I
want to do this and then actually doing
it and I've always been quick it didn't
always work quick but I started quick
the way I started in Nightlife and this
is going back to where I learned of the
Amish build a community build a tribe
it's funny it's like social media is
that's basically what social media is
it's like you've built your tribe you've
got subscribe it's like they just
they lock it in like you have one
million followers so it's kind of like
my tribe is one million and it's funny
how humans are chasing their tribe it's
like I want my subscribers everything
from YouTube Tick Tock but also like
only fans yeah guys if you want to join
the tribe all you got to do is hit the
Subscribe button only fair it's free
well you still have it someone signed up
for it randomly shut down do you feel
like you have to deliver now
60 Grand a month she doesn't do anything
nude yeah he just does feet
Adrian I'm gonna give you my login
I posted what I was buying for stocks
and I did that for a few weeks and then
I realized very quickly I was charging
too much and it wasn't worth my time
recharging 100 bucks so the conversion
rate is low and then I lowered the price
and I thought well it's not worth my
time that's insane not only fans
it just there's the power of community
in a world of free porn yeah
dudes all day long that you know the
this year the owner of only France has
been paying himself a million dollar a
day dividend no yep dividend net oh my
God so I was reading this in August
he had paid himself a million dollars a
day he's gonna probably do 365 this year
it's a good business but I'm going
tastic who are the dudes that but that
just showed you it's like people want to
feel like they belong so it's like I'm a
lonely guy here's a pretty woman that I
probably can't get in real life I could
be in her tribe I'll pay seven bucks a
month but I think a lot of that is the
personal connection uh we'll hit Stella
Barry on and she was making 250 300 000
a month consistently and I think she
chats with them right yeah but I think
it's a lot of them just want that
one-on-one attention but they don't
realize they're chatting with usually as
they're chatting with a gay assistant I
knew I met I went on Tinder date like
two years ago I don't know how many
years ago two three years you're on
Tinder yeah I always get kicked off
Tinder because it's like I get reported
as a fake one why but I feel like you
wouldn't I didn't say like you wouldn't
need to so in the U.S I've only done it
I did it for like a streak for like two
weeks I use it in like Scandinavia like
it's they're really shy yeah and like
Sweden Tinder is not like American
Contender it's like the most beaut
you're like this they are not charging
enough money for this but anyway I was
on I went on this date in San Diego
well I've only been on a few Tinder
dates in the U.S right and so this girl
comes probably the curviest woman I've
ever seen okay curviest white girl on
earth natural I was like
anyway I was after talking I was like
what do you do and she's like I'm on
only fans I was like I can believe you
make a lot of money she's like I'm
number three or something on there wow
and then it was funny we're in La Jolla
as we're talking Adrian she goes so she
just slides in that her Navy SEAL
husband is
deployed right now that's why she can be
on a date with me I'm like oh no no I
was like I'm getting out of here did she
recognize you like she didn't say it a
lot of times people won't say when they
recognize so you're saying like on dates
you've gone on dates where the girl knew
who you were yeah sometimes or usually
people won't say I find a lot of people
don't want to say like I know who you
are some people will but yeah this
girl's like I'm gonna get killed I'm
like right now she's like yeah don't
worry my Navy SEAL husband I'm glad you
gotta put that on your name you gotta
put that on your Tinder I have a husband
and he's a Navy SEAL and I'm hiding this
we don't have an open relationship yeah
she's like oh he's no not he wasn't even
deployed he was like in Kate Pendleton
it's like 45 minutes away anyway but she
was making like 500 000 but she's the
one who told me I go how do you talk to
all these dudes she's like I have a gay
assistant who just sits there so all
these guys are like oh I've connected
with this curvy woman and it's a it's a
good Hustle Man wow do you still have
Tinder the U.S I don't use like I said
I'll use it yeah it always gets it
always gets deleted for like being fake
people report that's crazy what do you
do for dating now while we're on a
Social Circle I mean I Instagram you
meet a lot of people I feel like
Instagram DMS is like the new Tinder
yeah you know I was just like talk but
when I was I've been in Puerto Rico so
I've been more chill I have you know but
when I was in LA you know how La is la
is just like an insane place I always
tell guys if you are an insecure man
and not good talking with women move to
LA because the most extroverted women in
the world move there and uh
just pretend like you recognize him I
heard this comedian for him on war he's
like La just go up to anybody be like
I'm a big fan you can go to any
nightclub be like big fan of your work
women will be like oh good because now
with social media what percentage of La
women that are pretty do you think are
some kind of interest in New York what
if she has like 500 followers the point
is when women are when humans are
narcissists they just are like thank you
you know what does she think that you're
mistaking them for somebody else that'd
be funny if you go and everywhere else
yeah you're you're thinking with common
sense my friend it's a good test though
because if she likes you she'll just be
like oh thanks but what if but what if
they have an only thing what if you're
like hey I like your work
exactly but New York's hard I think New
York's a hard City for people it's more
like yeah but the thing is if you go up
and you start with I'm a fan of your
work doesn't that show too much interest
right up front oh yeah all of a sudden
now that she's you know
yeah you're a fan and like I know it's
so funny you know it's like you're
Dynamic half I I don't totally subscribe
to this stuff
that's online now now there's like very
much like the Zeitgeist is like here's
how you play it you're the alpha man I I
think human psychology is very complex
so I don't know that that always
I I know very beautiful women that if
you play kind of the alpha cocky thing
you're gonna instantly fail like it's
used to it is a thing yeah like madly
used to fakeness I'm guessing but people
are too oversimplifying like human
attraction is complex it's like
basically I like to study Game Theory
right so you know I don't know if you've
ever seen the movie with Russell Crowe
uh beautiful mind it's about it's about
Nash who won a Nobel Prize in Game
Theory so like game theory for example
says if all men start to act certain way
it no longer works anymore then the
opposite will start to work so like if
all men are taught to be like super
cocky Alpha then the beta guy will start
to do better
if all men are start to act beta then
the alpha will stand up that's just like
finding the outlier in the group yes but
it's also I mean there's masculine women
and feminine women and there's masculine
men in film dude I know guys that are
super quiet with women not Alpha that
destroy any of the pickup artist guys
you know it's like it's not that simple
I actually you know the first paid
program I built because people think of
me like 677 the first one I built was
I forget what I call I called it Mr X it
was based on this dude that I had met
when I own nightclubs so when I took
over these nightclubs it was my first m
a deal it's a hostile takeover Colombian
dudes own this night nightlife thing in
North Carolina you were asking me and I
almost got killed doing this because I
took it over these guys were like big
coke dealers and I didn't realize it and
I like took I basically went to the
owner and I was like you shouldn't do it
with these Columbian guys I'll make you
way more money plus these dudes I think
the Colombian guys a lot of money I
didn't know I didn't know they were I
didn't know there were Coke dealers I
was like from the Amish I thought
everybody was nice I just was like these
guys are breaking all kinds of rules and
once in a while the fire department
would shut up show up and you get in big
trouble right and I was like the guy
that owned it I said these dudes they
don't they're gonna get your license
liquor license taken away so finally he
had a he didn't care because these
Colombian dudes brought all the hottest
women because of cocaine he was bringing
all the hot they were bringing all the
hot cokehead women so but I found his
conservative business partner and I went
to him and I was like you need to know
these guys are going to make you lose
your list and he threw them out put me
in they tried to kill me once it was
like a month later what happened there I
want to know basically I remember
Ricardo and Hernan that was her name
um
dude I took away like they controlled
like six clubs and in the back they were
like selling Coke and was like all this
and uh I was at a place and they like
all of like 10 dudes came in I was like
in a bathroom and I was like these
[ __ ] are gonna kill me Latin
dudes carry knives a lot my dad was
stabbed like my dad took his shirt off
him I was like these dude and I told him
I was like
I was like I forget what I said but
basically it was like fight or flight I
was like
you better kill me because if you just
half ass it like I'm gonna [ __ ] get
you back and they kind of a little bit
got scared they're not scared they were
just kind of like bluffed because they
were like pinning me in the back of this
place and that is when I rolled out
that's when I got a whole bunch of
security dudes I remember why didn't
they hurt you like I said I was a weird
I don't know that they were fully
committed to it but it was like
intimidation yeah but it was more there
were these were like real deal dudes I
didn't know that at the before but um
yeah I got all I got these 10 big
security guys to run my club out of
Brooklyn I had a seven foot two guy the
next week I sent all of them to those
dudes house in a car I mean in a van
they rolled up and I said just go knock
on the door and be like oh this is where
you live don't say [ __ ] in these big one
thing I've learned is Colombian dudes
are well I shouldn't say Colombian
everyone's afraid of big black guys it's
like they're like the alpha of physical
specimens and these dudes were all like
seven foot two I had a God it was seven
two and six eleven two brothers they
just showed up on their house and they
were like yo we work for Thai like this
where you live and then they got back in
the car and drove off that was in never
anything happened after that like I said
uh
yeah it was very opposite to Amish so
how much opposite of the Amish it sounds
like how much Capital did it take to
start up this nightclub none because I
did like I just moved in so maybe 10
grand promotion right so yeah but I got
I I took in a I was a partner with okay
that was when I did my first as I now I
do a lot of m a
you know merger and acquisition you can
acquire one of the biggest things I'm
working on a book called The Way of the
billionaire it's kind of what I've
learned from mentors that are
billionaires and most entrepreneurs are
very in love with the idea of starting
something from scratch like you have an
idea you're in the shower you grow it
but I mean look at Elon Musk it's like
almost everything he's done in the last
20 years Tesla was started by two guys
2003 Elon comes and what does he do he
inject 6 million and takes the thing
over in two rounds and he didn't start
Twitter and he likes to buy existing
stuff so I tell people now it's I didn't
know it back then but it's a great
strategy because you get all the
momentum that's already there and um
that's why franchises for example like
the average person
who starts a business I think it's
something like 80 percent of new
businesses fail but only five percent of
franchises fail so people who buy a Taco
Bell or McDonald's or Chick-fil-A
because the concept is already fleshed
out you know so when I got in that
nightclub business I didn't know at a
very high chance of success because it
was already like fleshed out you know
who is Mr X oh so Mr X when I bought so
when I took her as a nightclub I fired
everybody because they had all these
crazy dudes working for him but Giorgio
the main owner of the restaurant he said
Ty don't fire the door man I said why
trust me he goes this guy is responsible
for like a hundred hot women a night
will show up because he's there so I was
like what so I kept him
and um
and first day I met him and the guy was
he was a strikingly good looking dude
when you met like I'm I'm straight but
you'd be like oh [ __ ] I don't want don't
leave what's the thing don't leave your
girl around this guy but he was a cool
dude man and um he's the one who first
told me about Scandinavia basically come
to America to make enough money go and
then he'd go live in Sweden Denmark
Iceland but he was the he's the best guy
I've ever met with women and he was
partly because he was good looking but
he would he had and I know a lot of the
pickup artist guys and I respect those
guys and the guys who teach social stuff
and they're good but none of them are
this guy was like also a natural most of
the people who teach kind of started out
nerdy then hacked the system to be
better but it's also cool to see a dude
who started out like an 8.5 but also
hacked the system and he was a 10. so
one of the things I learned from for
example
like I mean this dude was shocking and
and the thing is he had the most
beautiful women in love with him like
Victoria's Secret model I have no I
think he's dead now I've not heard from
him literally like five years he lived a
little bit crazy life as an alcoholic
but one of the things I said his name
was Drago was his real name Puerto Rican
and Romanian I was like Drago I've been
out with you like you get shocking
amount of women coming up too and I was
like what's your
close rate on like getting a girl's
number he's like 50 percent
and I thought it was gonna be like he
got 90 and so now to myself like when
you're out and you've like even the best
dude only gets 50. and I told him how do
you deal with rejection he goes
I just tell myself I'm looking for the
women who have good taste so if they say
no to me it's like [ __ ] them they don't
know what they're talking about it's a
very confident guy and you know he was I
remember last time I saw him he's like
come to this club
Hollywood and Vine and as I was driving
there I was almost there he just like
texted me he's like I met two sisters in
the line I'm going home forget it I mean
it was correct this dude if I could ever
mate so I tried to make a whole course
around them and put them on video and
he's like you know what I'm kind of shy
so I just called it Mr X and I like
taught oh that was my first course and
it was so going back to this it was the
algorithm of a woman's brain and I think
in terms of Attraction and I think
there's 12 kind of algorithmic quick
computations a woman makes with
attraction and interesting couple years
about six years ago I was in Vegas and I
gave this talk there was a dating
conference and um there was a dude in
the back who came up to me this old guy
and he's like that was a pretty good
talk but you're missing one thing I
remember thinking who is this guy turned
out as Dr David Buss he's like the
founder of the Harvard evolutionary
psychology department he's become my
mentor he's like the smartest guy
probably the most respected psychologist
alive right now on social dynamics so he
said my basic idea was right I was
missing stat he said status you're
missing status is the most powerful
thing so you can be like people don't
realize like Justin Bieber is not tall
but Justin Bieber I dated a girl who
used to date him and she's like I go
over his house it's like 40 women on the
couch with just him all of them like him
love you know in love with her but he
was like you know he's like Justin
Bieber yeah yeah but I'm saying that but
he's not the richest guy
he's not the tallest he's not the most
Alpha you know but he has this other
thing which is status which means other
people respect him on both both genders
too yeah but there's other things anyway
so can you list off maybe like two or
three key components yeah this is for
you know just anyone watching yeah
research purposes yeah well I think look
I think women
um
I learned from Dr Buss I think I was
wrong I was missing but so I think
status is the most powerful if you look
have you seen that recent meme where
Jeff Bezos was with his girlfriend oh
DiCaprio was there yes so that was Laura
Sanchez his girlfriend is like looking
at the she's with the richest man in the
world and here's DiCaprio and she's just
like huh yeah so I always tease him like
this pulls away from him to go and talk
to Leo and the funny thing is Leo seems
completely disinterested just could not
care and he's just like you know kind of
making making amends to you know make
sure everything's good but there's Bezos
right he's just looking yeah because a
lot of times yeah
don't let your girl around DiCaprio I
went to a Thing Once Rihanna had a party
and I I met DiCaprio he's also not a big
dude he's a little guy
so I think that you asked me for the
quick list
um I think women look at intelligence I
think they look at ambition
I think they look at how far you've come
I think they look at facial symmetry is
one I think they look at height is
definitely one
um age range is one women almost all
cultures women like older men not
necessarily crazy older I think that
women so basically what women do it's
like okay if you're ugly in the face
but like I used to have these bouncers
that work for me some of these dudes are
like six eight three hundred pounds okay
someone ugly as hell but they're always
gonna pull some women being six eight
because that part of the computation of
women goes to like a 10 and their face
being ugly
is like a one it kind of dragged the
algorithms pulls it up so basically
you're born with a set of genetic
parameters that limit you and this isn't
just for human sexual attraction but
this is also in every area I mean humans
are extremely status driven and people
don't realize that you know if you put
150 chickens in a room they all look the
same to us but the chickens know who's
number one two three four five all the
way they keep track of that pecking
order so there's a pecking order with
people I think most that's why most
dudes who are rich are ugly
name a good looking really a good
looking like a Forbes guy I think you
have like Zuckerberg you have I mean
there's a few I don't know probably
actors don't qualify for that that's
Snapchat
yeah he's like at the bottom I'm talking
about tombow Forbes list guys you have
but he's a good looking guy Elon Musk
baby we're in their 60s and 70s like to
be in the top you got to be old that is
a good point let's talk about like Young
disproportionately Rich so the richest
would be Zuckerberg
no woman's phone is set to Zuckerberg
man this is zero
I mean there's zero yeah his wife maybe
that's funny no that parameter is like
the top there's got to be somebody no it
look yeah what I'm saying is it's
disproportionately I notice if like with
investors I have a big investor group
like these high net worth people it's
like there's a lot of there's a lot of
physically wrong here I love it
won't listen to this I'm just going
they're not a lot of there's not a lot
of Mr X guys there there's none yeah
sure I I'm telling you if you're if like
if you have kids don't you don't want
your son to be like this Mr X guy Drago
that worked for me he was a doorman and
he never had to be more than that to
live a badass life like he just you know
you look at the great people that do
great things you need kind of but now I
think to get to that level of wealth you
have to be so focused that you're
working on the business and not
socializing so that aspect doesn't get
nurtured and improved but do you think
maybe it could be because they're not
physically as attractive that they that
they try to make a lot of money to come
compensate I think you think it's just I
think dudes compensate Manhattan you
know I think women do do feeling
inferior is sometimes I would say most
of the time a better driver and
motivator and ambition you know than
just wanting to do a lot with your life
like feeling like you need to catch up
to be where you want to name a beautiful
scientist like people go in the lab man
I remember my my my buddy got his PhD
I probably shouldn't say it's not
politically correct but I went to his
graduation he's like I want you to look
at the women graduating from me he's
like Nate I want you to rate one to ten
the beauty on this stage because
everybody was on stage he's like show me
one five
and uh so the hard truth is yeah humans
have to cope all of us and I I saw that
uh what's his name
oh uh Jamie Foxx said that recently he's
like if it comes too easy
you ain't gonna strive for it you know
what I mean and that's why most Sons or
Daughters of wealthy people
like
they lose it daddy made it they lost it
they didn't have that drive there's a
few I mean Donald Trump's dad was
successful and he's kind of done well
but
I was just like Tom Hanks you know he's
it's like drug addiction
yeah the sun's just become they don't
have you need that burning fire in you
you need to dance your childhood
probably have to Dance with the Devil a
little bit you know you look at Elon
Musk he's like a guy who was I think he
was he strikes me as somebody who was
like almost suicidal deep depression as
a child you know it did say an
existential crisis at like 12. yeah yeah
he read a book he said books people have
criticized me because I'll tell you
don't need to read books I'm like dude
Elon musk's sister just wrote a thing
recently and said I remember Elon
growing up he read two books a day you
know book changed his life Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy he said that's what
got him out of that that thing so yeah I
mean think about it and I I think of
humans I think of myself as a homo
sapien a mammal I don't necessarily
think of myself
I think we're too narcissistic so we
think we're this other class of organism
on Earth and um you know the natural
state of a dog if you leave a dog
enough food enough warm plate it doesn't
become a wolf man a wolf is out there
hungry and you see a wolf and it's like
lean and it moves fast so that's going
back to these ratios you need some
trauma in your life if you have too much
trauma
the ratio gets out of whack and you
become kind of insane so
humans they say at one point in human
history there was a hundred humans in
the last ice age say maybe only 100
humans where all the descendants are
like 100 200 survivors
which makes you wonder it's like okay
after you go from 200 to a lot a lot of
people were a lot of people were dating
their sister back then no Tinder you had
to I could explain a lot of people today
man West Virginia man
so I think let's let's continue on the
storyline a little bit more yeah uh
because most people know you obviously
from the commercials and ads and stuff
like that it's where you got billions of
views or whatever uh let's keep uh so
after this this uh nightclub thing how
much money do you think you were making
from that Nightclub at that time I was
big I mean those two businesses I don't
I wasn't even making a million but I I
was living I didn't have much expenses
so I was living a good life out I don't
know maybe half a million a year at what
age and my that was still in my 20s you
know or mid early to not early mid 20s
mid 20s so that was good but but it's
all about like I look back and
that's actually a sweet spot for people
to be in because
I st I you didn't there was no s I
didn't need anything fancy I didn't I
didn't even really realize like La
Beverly Hills I was living in Raleigh
North Carolina
so for me all that extra money was like
freedom I started I remember I was
dating this girl Shara
and she goes I want to go to Puerto Rico
they have the world salsa dancing
competition and I had grown up kind of
poverty mentality so I immediately was
like no I can't go it took me I had to
reprogram myself that wait a second I
actually have money in the bank so I
said no and then like 10 minutes later I
was like why can't I go Google it was
like 500 to go and I go oh I can get a
ticker for you and she goes oh now I
can't go my friend Amanda is visiting me
and I said I can buy her a ticket too so
it was like a time of great freedom I
actually liked that time there were
around that time there was a time when
um I got like my first nice cars like
Ferrari Maserati and I just I remember I
just moved to LA I kind of got burned
out and I was like I'm just gonna get in
the car and drive and I drove for a year
I went La I went to Dallas I met this
girl there like randomly and we moved in
together for like a month or two and
then I forget I don't know if she got
sick of me or I got sick of her like I
moved out I went to Miami I'm running
the nightclub in the car oh so I had set
it up so I set up that one of my friends
took it over I gave him 20 of the
business and I didn't even have to show
up now when you do that it slowly goes
downhill I just want you to know but I
was it still spun off enough money it
went to like half but I sometimes I
think it's like would you rather make a
hundred percent of the money than have
to be there all the time or 50 of the
money there's two the two big
billionaires in American history is JD
Rockefeller he was worth estimated 600
billion in today's dollars and then
Carnegie Andrew Carnegie who was worth
about three or four hundred billion but
Carnegie early he kind of did the four
hour work week thing of uh you know Tim
Ferriss yeah I just re-read he wrote a
book called The Gospel of wealth and he
sold his company in 1901 for 350 million
dollars just let you know how much money
that was I mean that day was the richest
man in the world and he said
um he looked down on people that had to
work all day he said if you're a good
entrepreneur you pack it in efficiently
in the morning he's like I work I double
check everybody's so that Carnegie is
the most underrated probably person to
study so back then with my nightclubs
when I was traveling I inadvertently
kind of did the Carnegie thing I didn't
do it as well as Carnegie because
you should check up every day how is it
because you see a lot of entrepreneurs
are like a lot of advice I think most of
the advice I'll have the advice I see
online now from people teaching business
is very dangerous advice because it's
like 90 true but the 10 that's not will
kill you and one of those things is like
you set up a business you systematize it
you get other people running it for you
and then you can basically you know but
that's it's not true I've tried that
it's a very deadly thing what you can do
systematize the business
put someone else to run it
and double check it every day for a
short period of time like 15 minutes so
Sam Walton called that the Walt the
Walmart founder he called that
over-the-shoulder management so when I
was traveling I took the nightclubs and
I would only check on them like once a
month
I was like man if I only knew that
advice I would have called the dude once
a day that's what Carnegie would do like
9 A.M he'd call his main manager and be
like report to me what's up show me the
financials from yesterday and so since I
as I travel around the US for a year
after about a year that business kind of
dissipated down you know but but it was
fun it was free I was free camping I
just go to hotels I had enough money man
I would go to Montreal I stayed there
for a month I was just that's my
favorite life we're spending most of
what you made or you were investing at
all
um I was investing I would say I was it
was a combination but I wasn't making
crazy money I mean if you make 500 000
after taxes it's not insane money you
know taxes people don't realize eat you
up and then in general the more money
you make the more you're going to spend
so
it was a decent it wasn't I wasn't
burning through all of it but I wasn't
building a uh I wasn't like uh at what
at what point though did you decide to
change that lifestyle and dive into
something else about the time you met me
a little really a little bit after that
prior 2009 I don't even know why either
I think it's probably meeting Graham it
was probably set that yeah I was like I
never want to live in this place that he
brought me to and it's like I have to
create money man yeah well I mean like I
think now like this year my holding
company I I have a holding company so I
own a lot of Brands it's gonna do
probably 850 million of Revenue and back
then I was like tried to do a million
but you know in many ways
um I guess I pushed the limits of my
ambition to try to see where I I think
that
there's the most noble way to think
about it live life is to keep all the
things in Balance but yeah 2009 things
were very much in Balance how did you
get on the the show with Patty what was
your Patty Schlesinger Patty Stanger
Stanger yeah for millionaire yeah how do
you get on dude my friend Sam Rima was
this Playboy casting guy that I had met
at the Playboy mansion and but he was
also casting for non-playboy stuff I was
he wasn't trying to cast me I don't have
your Lukas Graham so but anyway he he
goes uh yo there's a show why don't you
come down so I just showed up and you
had to you had to show you were a
millionaire and now I was like right
when I had kind of control
yes I was like
and uh and I got on that show that was
great that was like that was in the
Myspace days yeah can you explain what
exactly that show is it was just like a
dating show it's like all the guys are
supposed to be millionaires you go out
with women it was kind of half scripted
half it's like the batch
I loved it so they get the two
millionaires together and the
millionaires are always very eccentric
yeah like one guy was like who was
getting fed grapes I forget maybe that
was that wasn't me that wasn't meant on
the couch and wanted to be fed grapes
and it's just some wild stuff but but
interview the two millionaires find out
who they like and then have a mixer
where there's maybe like 15 to 20 women
down there and they just kind of talk so
two Millionaires and two million women
it's kind of like The Bachelor on crack
on financials 60 Minutes 60 minutes yeah
they had 60 Minutes
um but but they met people that they
wanted to go on a date with and then you
pick up this yeah you maybe pick five
that you want to talk to for 20 minutes
one-on-one and then you pick one to go
on a date with I went on a boat that was
my mistake I was there I hate boats I
get seasick so I was in a bad mood on
that damn boat and then I didn't get
along with the main lady it was her show
wait with like the host of this yeah so
it was like I learned don't do that I
just she just she was uh we were both
too strong-willed people she did she
wanted me to wear a different shirt oh
we my friend played a joke yeah they
took too long to do our wardrobe so we
just went out and met the girls with no
shirt on just as a joke which I was like
it's California if we're out of [ __ ] and
she was like really thought that was bad
I was like don't be so fast that was
scripted that was your no that wasn't
what happened they had us on this like
you know where you get like powdered up
and sitting and so we added something
about our shirt I guess the makeup they
were trying to put makeup and I was
finally like ah I'm here it was hot so I
just took my shirt off and went out to
meet the women and they just kept the
cameras rolling my episode was like
number one most watched for like five
years because the shirtless gagging yeah
that and because I didn't get along with
Patty
you're like two years later she was
doing a book signing and I went there to
say hi she wouldn't talk to me serious
because I'm like it's not like I punched
you in the yeah she's very sensitive she
would but she was became super she'd be
happy because of you oh it was good
ratings yeah you want somebody like me
you want it was like before the
Kardashians you need like knowing it
would be a vibrant I didn't know that
the camera followed this was before a
lot of virality yeah and this was like
I've always been able to go viral
sometimes to my own uh you know to my
own arm but yeah that went I remember
waking up and like
it was funny so this is going back to
like women certain women were like mad
they're like you're not a gentleman you
took your shirt off to meet this so I
had on MySpace this is a nice way look
at it all this backlash
from but then there was these other
women who all the women who kind of like
like eccentric dudes and I remember man
the most beautiful one of the most
beautiful women in L.A just like
started hanging out with me and I was
like that's why I tell you don't ever go
by the hard and fast rules there's a
woman who likes every type of dude
goofy dude eccentric dude you know weird
certainly some dudes get more volume I
mean get more of a percentage of the
cohort of humans but
yeah so for you where's the point of
diminishing returns for money people
always ask me it's like Ty what's your
net worth I'm like I want my net worth
online to be relatively low I think you
want your net worth as a dude I can I
can't speak for Life as a woman but I
can speak for Life as a man like you
want five million to be your net worth
online because
if you lose anything if you lose a male
or woman who googles you at 5 million
you didn't want them as friends you
didn't want them in your life and 5
million shows that you're like enough
you know that you are good enough
but July 5 versus 10.
at five I heard 10 means you maybe could
be too focused on money five means
you're just a diligent investor and
you're just well I'm saying even if
you're worth 50 you want your damn you
want to be five I remember when I first
moved into this place in Beverly Hills
that everybody kind of saw that video
the first month I had a maid come her
first day on the job like oh she didn't
show up the second day
week later I get this letter she was
suing our health insurance
she said she slipped on a banana peel
I remember thinking it's like she don't
even have it she just made something up
to try to make money you know Jeff Bezos
is housekeeper that's suing him for uh
improper work conditions yeah she said
that there was not a proper rest area or
restroom for her to use in his house
dude you know Graham forced me into a
closet one time but you know we're gonna
we're gonna get after that
but they say that she was fired for poor
work performance and that she was making
over a hundred thousand dollars a year
how much was she she doesn't say
undisclosed amount I think the goal is
usually to say a huge amount and then
settle of course and so even if she
settles 500 000 bucks for him it's a
penny yeah she goes away and she makes
500. yeah that's all I'm saying that's
what I'm saying basically you're saying
if you show that you're a high net worth
it the Predators that could potentially
come in America it's like America's
solid it's the kind of the end of
America if people don't realize it's
like the legal system's out of whack you
can't have that's what destroys
civilization is too many people preying
on stupid things you know so yeah that's
like so going back to diminishing
returns I mean man if you're a dude
and now I have a lot of followers I
actually pulled my followers on Twitter
like a month ago I said what is your
minimum goal you'll be happy it was I
was surprised like I put a hundred
thousand a year 300 500 million a
million one in like a landslide so I
don't know if it's inflation
that everybody thinks you need a million
or
I think now with Tick Tock and
everything it's like social media is
reprogramming people's brains this is a
million dollars just like an annual
annual yeah they were thinking of it I
think as net but how many people just
say a million dollars you're like that's
cool and they just click a million
without thinking about it uh maybe but I
actually think it's reflecting like what
social media is doing I mean you go on
social media and it's like people were
bothered that I put Lamborghinis it's
like Lamborghinis and like I I got a
kick out of this Tick Tock I saw it's
like some kid he's 21 he's like this is
my struggle this is my journey like one
year ago I was working at McDonald's
four months later I learned how to
whatever day trade Forex or something
and now oh I think I know now 12 months
later I'm driving my Lambo traveling the
world in Dubai and I was go and he's
like don't give up I'm going is that a
struggle it's like bro I stuck over like
four weeks
it's the guy that you're thinking about
it's so fun but I'm saying that's like
the Chinese there's this Theory you know
that the Chinese are using Tick Tock to
reprogram civilization uh it might be
true that algorithm is like tweaking
people's brains I saw Jordan Peterson a
psychologist you know he said now a boy
a teenager is exposed to more beautiful
women than he would ever see in his
entire life a hundred years ago so it's
like now people's standards are like
sure everybody's and when women are all
depressed because your feed is just full
of light so it's a
it's a weird one that's so you have to
really control your brain now in the
modern world and you have to say let me
stay logical let me not be reprogrammed
by somebody else's happy life algorithm
let me know what I want you know and I
but I do think some of the algorithm is
good like here's something more people
nobody has critical thinking skills very
few people have the ability to see
something and think what do I think and
give their own opinion based on
everything else so many people to see
that and they're like that must be a
fact because it has 20 million views on
Tick Tock x amount of people liked it
and then you get served everything else
that just reinforces that I think it's a
huge problem is I think the worst for
misinformation worse than YouTube
Twitter Facebook why do you think so uh
because their algorithm is so potent
that I think it'll Zone into whatever
you're gonna watch and I think uh
misdiagnosing medical conditions is one
of the biggest problem on Tick Tock and
now people are getting self-diagnosed
with ticks all right with certain
Tourette's syndromes uh ADHD there's so
many things that'll just keep showing
it's also supervised so for example if
you lean into one thing it'll just
basically like reaffirm that whatever
Echo chamber yeah exactly you could be
on conservative Tick Tock liberal Tick
Tock and it just keeps feeding that to
you and you just become more extreme in
whatever Behavior speaking of tick tock
tie I'd be curious to hear what your
thoughts on Andrew tadar people have
compared Andrew Tate's marketing you
know like you can always appear to
basically everywhere and everyone's
screen similar to your marketing back in
like you know the early uh yeah 2010s
yeah I get that's like a really common
question it's funny before he was famous
he was like dming me before in like a
couple years ago and so we we and him
talk
um
recently we were going to meet up in
London and then I like went to DM and
he's gone off Instagram and we got
banned and I didn't have I had to go on
his website I'd do his little instant
messenger and I was like yo we were
gonna meet up
can I talk to Andrew and so the dude is
like an assistant is like
I don't believe you're Tai Lopez I was
like I'm really Tai Lopez like you're
gonna have to prove it so I was like
okay go on telegram I had to like shoot
a video like yo this is actually me all
the people that go viral
the garyvee's the grant cardone's the
Joe Rogan's you know the Tates they're
sharp and most it's hard to go viral for
a long period of time unless you have
some unique angle so I put them in you
know high IQ person that and takes a
belief
to the nth degree that's what really
like the algorithm
rewards extremes that was about to say
it rewards extremes which is for good or
bad you know the Kardashians
Kanye Kanye is probably the most Google
person Donald Trump Elon can be pretty
extreme he says all this stuff on on
Twitter that like gets him in trouble
with the SEC so I mean there's a good
and bad to that in this and I've been
there too like I've showed an extreme
side it was actually my life but I
showed it and it was like super extreme
to the average person you know it's like
living this life in Hollywood and people
and so when I talk about reading a book
a day that was at the beginning before I
really went viral but that was kind of
extreme and people were like ah but it
went viral so I think you know whether
it's Tate or Trump or Kanye or AOC like
on the left side or Ben Shapiro and
stuff the the algorithm is going to
reward extreme views for good or bad and
so to some extent that's great for
society there's because like a tate he
brings out these Concepts that everybody
was afraid to say
which is like maybe radical feminism or
something or kind of I think correct me
if I'm wrong because I I try to not use
social media that much except I'm like a
drug dealer I'll deal it but I don't
want to use it for myself so I try to
limit my scrolling through the algorithm
but unless it's funny videos that's what
I that's the best use of social media
like funny videos is the best pranks and
all that but
um you know I remember the first time I
really saw Andrew Tate was talking about
how men are lonely and that was a that
one video clip is like a woman will
never understand
and I think social media from like 2018
to 20 whatever 21 had flipped so strong
to like the woman's side of you
and Men kind of felt like well you know
I don't get represented so Tate came in
and was like
saying what people were thinking that's
how that's how Trump whether you like
him or not I'm not that political he
says a lot of stuff that people think
I remember I was watching something he
said where
he goes why do we have to pay NATO
it's like why do we have to pay to
protect Germany they should have to
[ __ ] pay their proportionate amount
first president to say that it's true
it's logical like but that's one of
those touchy things like do you want to
say that so Tate is good at saying what
a couple hundred million people are
thinking Peterson and Jordan Peterson
yes does that too who knows Jordan
Peterson oh we'd love to have him on the
pocket we would love to have him on the
podcast this is an open invitation to
have Jordan on yeah he's now he's part
of the Ben Shapiro Ben's I know Ben
Shapiro there he's kind of linked up
with the daily wire and Ben's killing it
they got that app with some Insanity
amount of people paying 10 bucks a month
yeah and I don't know how Ben Shapiro
posts so much I see his I see his feed
and he's posting like four times a day I
need to start my Brand's been like the
last three years I've been too busy I'm
actually working on a show which is like
money talk kind of show a little bit
what I'm gonna do I I like talking about
what I call the good life because I
think
the Socrates good life yeah yeah exactly
yeah that's good that you know that you
know he called it he had a different
word for it like a Greek word but that's
what I was talking about the ratios of
The Good Life so my show I I try to even
though it's I'm I'm known so much more
for the money side because that was the
most extreme side but it's not my real
belief like I do think Steve Jobs said
you know I didn't want to be the richest
man in graveyard but he was because he
sucked at understanding Health he had
like wacky theories of eating bananas
and he took it and then you die of
pancreatic cancer they say it's not
related but I'm like well
couldn't have helped and so I think to
me I think you
I think I try to not just talk about
money even but that's what people want
me to talk about well let's talk about
money real quick how did you start off
with that uh here in my garage where
were you at in your life when that yeah
I want to hear this story on this so I
was living in the Hollywood Hills
had a badass I enjoyed my life it was a
amazing life I was at a mastermind
somebody's like you do good on YouTube
and you should do YouTube ads to boost
your stuff I was at a mastermind so I
tell people to go to like masterminds
and conferences I don't even remember
who was sitting next to me I thought on
it and I had just bought this got this
Lamborghini I was dating this girl and
she I was like she wanted to be Batwoman
and I was like I'll be Batman I'm gonna
get a black Lamborghini I wanted one
anyway and so
that was in October
2014 and then I go let me listen to this
dude and do start boosting some ads so I
shot a video with my friend Jeremy and
he I tried to do it as an ad and it made
like no money I lost 20 grand I spent 20
grand in December 2014 and I made like
one grand back
and um but I knew enough about marketing
that it's all about a b testing
iteration so I didn't give up I went for
New Year's I went to Paris uh for New
Year's and
when I was there my assistant you know
Nathan Nathan I loved books I had all
these I would order crazy amount of
books I did was doing that back on the
Amish days I would like all my money I'd
spend on books and be delivered you know
I was like Amazon was first starting
they delivered to the Amish Amazon
shipments not on horses you order the
Amazon I would like they didn't have a
phone but then you could go use like a
pay phone oh my gosh I'd like call
somebody who would order them for me I'd
be like he I forget the whole but I had
like a I also would get these vintage
books but anyway so I went and I took
that
I shot a nut oh he called me I'm in
Paris die what do I do with all these
books so I had like crazy amount of
books and I'd filled up the entire house
I had a pretty big house
I said yo buy bookshelves and stick them
in the garage I'll be back and I'll
figure it out so I came back first week
of first couple weeks of January
and there's all these books there and
um it was I remember it was a Sunday it
was like January 18th or 19th and my
friend called me I had I had this really
smart friend who's now my business
partner Dr Alex Mayer and he had said
some advice to me he would come down
from San Fran he was building his tech
company he sold it a couple years ago
for 300 million but back in 2014 he was
building it and he came down to visit me
and I was like let's go out to a club
and he's like you know
parting's overrated Ty he kind of like
chastised me and I was like damn okay so
he was gone at that point he had gone
back to San Francisco but that Sundown
supposed to go out to a club
with a friend and they texted me like
where are you and I texted back parting
is overrated I'm gonna sit here and I'm
gonna make some content so I was all
alone that day because I was no one was
I was supposed to meet everybody and I
just grabbed a camera and I knew I knew
about copywriting I started copywriting
like oh man a year I was doing that even
kind of in the nightclub days and so I
just wrote out some like opening things
and I knew you know there's 25
scientific cognitive biases scientists
identify these ways that the human brain
makes a decision they call it heuristics
like our brain is like a branching set
of like a branch if you say this yes
then it branches two more times so one
of the branches that's where they get
this concept of a hook or like a pattern
interrupt so I go what's a good pattern
interrupt and speaking of Sunset Plaza
do you know Sushiya Sushi of course so
I've had a lot of interesting
breakthroughs I met a dude in 2007 who
told me basically told me to buy Bitcoin
coin before it existed he's like this
new digital thing his name is Brock
Pierce I don't know if you know who he
is he's a billionaire now I had a dinner
with him at Sushiya but I also had
would observe it's this place it's kind
of like the dude who owns Sushiya has
the most beautiful women working as
waitresses it's a good business model
okay they're always out front because
they're they're on the sidewalk so and
they'll say hi to everybody every time
Hi how are you every dude goes there
because they think these women like them
I'm like ah okay but I had noticed one
pattern when the most beautiful actress
woman in Hollywood walked by
all if you'd watch I've been a student
in Psychology you'd like all men's eyes
will follow her but
if a badass car was going by at the same
time as a girl the dudes would override
looking at the woman and look at the car
so that that Sunday night I'm sitting
in my kitchen and I'm like what's a good
hit hook I'm like you know what's
powerful and even sex Beauty
a damn Lambo so I'm like let me say here
I'm here my so and I also knew like
Authority right so what's an authority
City to say where you are if I'm like yo
I'm here and you know
Omaha Nebraska it's not it's not like
good copyright but I was in Hollywood
Hills and everybody kind of knows
Hollywood so I was like working it in I
I didn't script the whole thing out but
I just kind of like wrote a rough s line
I was like okay put in Hollywood Hills
Lamborghini's good but then I was like
okay don't sound too materialistic bring
use these hooks to bring people around
to something worthwhile for civilization
which is like books have changed the
world man you know it's like and you can
track human civilization really changing
from the invention of the Gutenberg
Press in 2015 I mean in uh the 1500s so
I wrote here in my garage just got this
new Lamborghini and I was like this
Hook's gonna cook people right here
oh my gosh I said but you know what I
like more and I practice that pan I
probably shot that 15 times because the
pan I went the wrong way a few times and
I was like let me pan around it was
before like your iPhone you couldn't tap
the flip is good it's always like I was
kind of like should I flip that do I
turn my phone around so I was like let
me just pivot yeah and I was like but
what I like more is his books knowledge
yeah and boy that phrase It's actually
like a good thing I'm like you know if
you if something I'm Gonna Be Remembered
for some kind of meme thing at least
it's like the word knowledge it's like
actually a useful word for civil like
Focus humans on knowing [ __ ] that's what
makes humans different than other
species if you really think about it's
like dogs can run faster gorillas are
stronger but humans have the ability to
collect collate and act upon knowledge
very quickly not not just Instinct like
your dog
the only knowledge and I like your dog
but he's not the smartest tool in the
shed right the average dog has an IQ of
like 20 to 30. they can't yeah they're
smarter than I thought yeah well like
border call you have a smarter kind of
dog like Border Collies are pretty smart
okay I've seen my friend has a dog Alex
has a dog that dog may not even have an
IQ it was a dumbest dog in the world and
his wife has a dog that still doesn't
know his own name I don't know I mean
I'm like a guy that you know what's that
little dog that has Lexi I mean it is
the dumbest so yes you're right so the
smarter dogs are 30. but anyway so I did
that knowledge thing but then what
people don't realize is it what I re I
hate watching myself on video okay I
only I did not watch here in my garage
after I shot it until like two months
ago really yeah I don't like it it's
like do you really like watching
yourself on camera it's like [ __ ] that
did you know how to edit it or did you
just send them no I set it off oh really
I sent it off my friend it you probably
saw little clips of it because yeah I've
seen Clips oh for sure I I saw but but I
I went like two months ago and I watched
the whole thing and I was like that the
reason that worked because it was good
copywriting it was and then I what I did
script was the landing page video so
there was an hour Lander selling the 67
steps and that I pretty much wrote out
no wasn't that 67 a month yeah it was a
buck a month you get one video that
course you know I traveled around the
world dude people come up to me like
that thing changed my life it's actually
a pretty powerful
that that 67 steps is a pretty powerful
thing I just had somebody
take I'm gonna turn it into a book and I
asked him to like transcribe it and
they're like holy [ __ ] they're like you
should get this out it's I had to revise
it because it would be uh 2 000 Pages
because it's 67 hours of talking yeah so
now I'm curious when you when you first
ran that was it an immediate success it
was it crushed so I turned it on I shot
it on a Sunday and
let's say I turn the ACT edited it
Monday Tuesday my editors got up
Wednesday I had a conference remember we
used to do the Roosevelt were you ever
had any of those so the Roosevelt you
know Hotel I had a conference there I
was still doing some like self-help
stuff okay I go there and I'm talking in
the morning and in the back is my friend
and he's laughing the whole time and I
walk back there and I'm like what's so
funny he's like bro look at this and
it's like we spend like 50 Grand on ads
and make like a hundred and thirty
thousand back in the same day wow it was
like he was like what the [ __ ] he's like
it was before targeting that's why I say
you have to wealth is created by a
combination of many things but one of
them is catching new trends early and
you were talking about how humans aren't
free thinkers so and what happens is
what it really comes down to
it wasn't until recently that a
scientist actually came up with this
term of risk averse humans are risk
averse that's in our DNA it's like
humans a thousand years ago if they took
too much risk they fell off a cliff or
they didn't have glasses they didn't
have antibiotics you didn't have all the
things we have now so taking risks was
very dangerous so new trends like Elon
Musk caught EV cars
when they were kind of doubted that
they'd be a real thing or Jeff Bezos
built a website in 1994. so all these
wealthy people for the most part are
catching Trends early and I'm not on the
level of a Elon Musk or whatever but
just catching that little YouTube ad
there was no competition
nobody was I was the only person who was
like a personal brand there was one guy
six pack shortcuts I don't know if you
remember that Talent Mike Chang he was
teaching you like oh he was an Asian guy
and he was like oh he's always in his
kitchen yeah and he was like yeah he was
like buy my course but there was nobody
doing it besides like six-pack shortcuts
so
it just like printed money I was like
and I've seen that over and over
actually in 2009 I had built some I got
in the Facebook beta program I'd seen
the same thing but it wasn't on the
level of YouTube yeah like Facebook ads
I would spend this is in maybe 2000 I
think it was 2009 I'd spend like two
grand and make 20 grand back I used to
make 10 row ass wow right away but
Facebook didn't have like YouTube has
that visceral video experience and
Facebook back then wasn't really video
so it's just like image ads so I had
seen catching and like I said when I
started in Google AdWords being one of
the first person
I could make fifteen hundred dollars off
a hundred and fifty dollar spent 10x
Facebook had that but YouTube was just
like super exciting how much were you
making from that like how much did that
67 steps make oh I made like probably
now maybe it's made almost 100 Mil but
let's say let's say conservatively 75. I
I I checked years ago it was like seven
I remember but that's that's in Revenue
yeah but it was high margin right I mean
it's just the cost of ads which yes but
after a while it was people were just
buying it on their own they would tell
their friend about 10 million bucks in
ads maybe 15. yeah yeah I mean you're
probably talking they'll probably talk
let's just I don't know but I put a lot
of that money back into growing my brand
like I because Russia paid too much
taxes like it's you is I was living in
California yeah I mean you want to make
20 30. you were living in that house it
was like 50 Grand a month right 60. you
mean in Beverly Hills yeah no that was
93 000 a month wow how is it expensive
because that much because 17
000 and 19 bathrooms and 17 bedrooms is
a big house but that's where you made
the video though no that was in the
place before that was in 2014 then I
moved in about 26. because I doubt you
would have been able to afford 93 before
though I wouldn't even have thought of
it that came later that the reason I got
such a big house that 93 000 is I had an
office in Sunset Plaza right next to
Sunset Plaza there's this place and I
had two floors there and it was 60 000 a
month right and then I did the math I
was like I can fit all these people in
this one I saw this one house is that
the one in the corner in La Cienega or
no no no that was in Beverly Hills okay
and I just did the math and I was like I
can just put my 50 staff people in this
house and have a house for not much more
than I'm paying for an office so I it
made economic sense it wasn't just you
leaving alone for I I wouldn't do that's
too much it's like too excessive but it
was a great office especially for
shooting content because I had all my
video people there it had a separate gym
basketball court swimming pool it was I
did the first big influencer party I had
1200 people dude you know how many big
people came out of that party I was like
that I remember Jake Paul and Logan Paul
were just you know they were in my
courses I was just on the Logan Paul
thing he's like dude we got in your
courses yeah they start out and like I
was doing this I did a party
early 2016. I was like come you have to
have I forget what was it 500 000
followers anyway 1200 people showed up
in my backyard it was insane I said
let's take a picture this will reach the
most people of any picture in human
history and it was like a billion people
I counted up before it was all these
people like Madison Beer was Now Matt
these people were like just that big
then it's like Jake Paul Logan Paul a
lot of people from Vine I'm guessing
yeah it was all that vine kind of early
YouTubers so that house was very
strategic I've thought of going back to
that house I got a lot of flack people
are like bro you rented this I'm like oh
yeah it's a rental yeah but I'm like
people thought it was a rental for like
one day I'm like I was there for five I
think I
or years so I'm like I mean the one
thing with the rental you're able to
write it off hell yeah and also when you
think of how the cost it would be to buy
that house and we'll pay more money
right buy it than rent it Beverly is
terrible well the problem the ROI in the
Beverly Hills Flats is like if you
bought a house and rented it out you
would be lucky to get maybe a two
percent return on your money yeah it's a
horrible yeah that's why I tell people
time the market so
you do you just do the math whether you
should lease or own right now with fed
raising interest rates now is the time
to come back in and buy but Beverly
Hills is not a place that will be
affected by the FED it's an unleveraged
Place everybody's Rich yep so no those
that house if you do the math way
smarter to rent yep way smarter because
like 40 million dollar house and you can
rent it for a million bucks yeah and I
remember the ads you filmed in those
houses so much content there they were
those ads would keep me watching because
they'd always be curious of like what
what like you're gonna get to my
favorite ad was when he goes into the
car and he's like showing you a pink
slip or something yeah
h3h3 came you know you know who hatred
yes yeah so like the first time I oh you
always get a little bit of hate but the
first dude that had a big following that
hated on me was really a tree usually
people would do a little Hater video I'd
check my insta DMS you'd have like one a
day out of 10 000 DMS saying I hate you
or whatever dude h3h I woke up one day
and I was like what the [ __ ] I checked
my DMs like and he had made that video
and he was like oh so I remember being
like should I retaliate or I'm just
gonna reach out and I invited him to the
house and when he came there he I was
like let me show you the [ __ ] you
know it's got my name on the what was
the title of the accusation that it was
a the rental for the day or something it
was like one of these crazy videos that
he does I don't know if you've ever seen
him like part goofy part serious
accusations but we became friends after
then he had me on his podcast
you know honey so it's like that house
was good it was a hub I sometimes I'm
like I should still be in that house
I've thought of like maybe I'll go back
to that house it's a good social media
it's just like La now is a social media
hub of the world I mean it's like the
most maybe you can do that in Miami it's
just California I don't like the taxes
and all that you know what's funny it's
one of my most viewed videos in the
first I don't know maybe the first year
when I started my channel was breaking
down your video okay and it was why Tai
Lopez ads are so effective and I went
through your your ads and would break
down why they work so well and how I
think it was the pattern interrupt was
something that I mentioned in there the
storyline but you kept deviating from
The Story You're like I'm gonna tell you
that the five ways to get rich oh by the
way this Lambo over here I got this is
so much fun to drive all right so the
first thing you need to do uh you know
what actually it's gonna be too long
sign up down below put in your email
it's always the email right and I
followed the whole thing because I was
so curious why it was so effective and I
studied that because I thought so
interesting that's what that's what
Logan Paul said when I met him he's like
dude I would watch your video and be
like what is this guy doing but really
it's like I said you have these 25
cognitive biases I've actually I've got
my own so now I think there's like 40
cognitive biases I've come up with kind
of subsets really going deep in
Psychology but you have things like
content fairness you have reciprocity
Authority social proof pavlovian
responses and all this stuff so I tell
people if you're an entrepreneur you
really should take the psychology part
to the nth degree to understand because
all money is really psychology well what
I liked about yours was that they were
filmed with an iPhone right and everyone
else's was so professional right made
you feel like they're about to sell you
something but your thing is like filming
with an iPhone I remember too you were
filming and like someone walked in the
front door and they didn't know your
film and they just closed the test yeah
my editors would always be like take it
out I'm like leave it yes yeah or you
drop something I'm like it looks real
man it looks real but I thought that
just disarms the viewer right and did
not thinking like ah he's just a random
guy yeah or an average guy and not this
is not like some professional expensive
setup even though the house in the
background was right was really
expensive yeah there was a lot of
Dynamics going on in those videos like
Harvard did like a case study on the
videos like people were like yo I'm at
Harvard or Wharton or whatever and
they're studying your video I think I
think at the end of the day if you look
at the richest man in the world now Elon
Musk he is really King psychologist he
understands he reads people very well
and you know I think I I had the last
conversation I he used to go to a lot of
stuff that I would go to and I I had
really interesting conversations with
them I posted a couple on my Instagram
but the last one I had
um
he said do you think I should use
Snapchat to grow my businesses and I was
like AB that was when Snapchat was big
like 2016 2017. those are the Game of
Thrones World premiere I was there and
uh we had just
he had sat next to me the month before
at a movie premiere so we were kind of
he didn't really know me but he
recognized me when he asked me that and
I said well yes and he listened to me
for like 20 minutes and at the end I'm
like
what do you think and he goes I think
you're wrong I don't think you need
social media and I remember for years I
used to tell that story of how Elon Musk
shut me up but now I'm like God damn it
I was right it was like test he it
wasn't snap it was Twitter like you need
this you it's when you're a master
psychologist like Elon Musk if you don't
have a forum
you can't scale your message very well
yeah so I was like for people this is
one of the problems with influencers now
especially people trying to become an
influencer so now you have the loud
megaphone that reaches let's say a third
of the world every day is on social
media two three billion people right but
since you haven't mastered psychology
you're kind of just doing all this
activity and it's not going to catch on
when you think of the Andrew Tates or
the hermosis or all the people that
people ask me about I'm like no they
first at some point I don't know all of
their stories
they mastered the psychology of
delivering content you know they're good
at it the pace the the vocal intonations
and also things like you said like
diverging off and what's interesting is
me my style is more one that meanders
and some people don't like it
you know people are probably divided if
you you ever seen 16 personalities no
it's like an online test right like ENT
oh yes
it's based on Carl Jung you know it's
jungian
psychology and so each of those letters
represent part of your personality and
one of them is called
an N versus an S an N is intuitive an S
is sensing sensing people like very
practical stuff so I've noticed certain
of the influencers
I don't even know I don't watch that
much but like some of them deliver you
because okay I'm going to tell you the
three ways to make money and they just
like write it right quickly then there's
other people who tell stories and
they're longer more Meandering
about half the population likes the
style where you just get right to it and
half of them likes the long Meandering
so I was attracted to people who like
the longer
Meandering versus here's the exact way
to create wealth because there is no
exact way to create wealth in fact I
could teach you how to create wealth but
everything's creating its opposite in a
world of free market capitalism
if I teach you what I did in 2016 it did
make me money but it won't work now
because too many people are doing it
yeah money's made as soon as you did
that everyone else began copying yeah I
think in the beginning it was you Grant
Cardone and Alex Becker that I think
we're doing fantastic at doing those ads
and then shortly after you get everybody
copying the exact same thing yes so now
what's working is more like if you see
what Andrew Tate did his was more like
podcast Snippets
it wasn't as much of him and and like
really strong
thing now I think if you see an ad like
that would devalue his brand right to
run any sort of AD whatsoever yes but if
you listen it's not just that he's
people are reposting he repo it's strong
content it's like ah you know I'm richer
than you know what's interesting kind of
this thing of like I'm richer than you
I'm the alpha colors you're Bugatti do
you remember like 10 years ago there was
a website called the rich jerk you ever
heard this is one of the best
copywriters he didn't put his face on it
I know the real dude his name is Kelly
Kelly Felix he built that whole thing
where he's like I'm the [ __ ] badass
listen to me pet plebs and it worked
back then but there wasn't the megaphone
2012 2013 like there was no Tick Tock so
it it it went he made he became I mean
he made many millions off that so that
she's nothing new Under the Sun man
people are just rehashing the same the
same hooks that work and the thing that
this this famous ad and the other you
know following ads were all routing to
was the 67 it was like Steps well I had
other stuff I built this smma course in
2016 called social media marketing
agency that
so many people got results making money
I would I'm like I would almost go if I
had a way to document this I would go to
head to head with anything
that's been put out college or otherwise
of taking more people from Rags to
Riches in that program I showed people
how to make one to ten thousand dollars
a month charging businesses to do their
Facebook ads and social media I built
this four month training course it was
insane I at one point I had a lawyer
half of his day was just
collecting all the testimonials and
verifying just like people were like I
made a hundredth even to this day I get
people it's a good time to start too oh
yeah I crushed so I 67 steps were first
then I then I build out different
specific systems like how you can 67
steps was more like a general mindset
and then smma was like a practical way
to build a business that's what Logan
Paul went into
those guys were all in that yeah he did
Airbnb I did Airbnb I've done all kinds
I've done how to build an e-commerce
scaling so I built like what I think how
much is that made combined
what do you think the net profit on that
is I don't know on the net but I mean
it's in the hundreds of millions I
haven't I I should know this right
um but it's it's
the reason I say I don't know exactly is
because so many things I do now like
do I count it as 67 steps or it up sold
into all this other stuff but I mean
it's in the hundreds of millions that's
insane why did you decide that it's not
all profit yeah but you have marketing
costs but it but why would you decide to
leave YouTube because you were doing so
well on that yeah or I would what was it
three four years where it really you
were dominating the YouTube ad space and
and posting consistently on top yeah I
started buying businesses and it just
like blew up
um and took a lot of my time like I
bought Pier One I bought Radio Shack I
bought dressbarn like I bought I just
bought just myself and an SPV we bought
75 of a publicly traded NASDAQ company
so the last three years has just been
like I just didn't have time you run out
of time and then yeah why did you do
that that's a great question because uh
what's the they said like why do you try
to climb Mount Everest because it's
there
that's probably why you know it's like I
think a lot of people would see like
Pier One and see these otherwise failing
businesses that are not doing well
wouldn't you think that that's going to
be like a blockbuster let's just let
them you know I tried to buy Blockbuster
I'd buy Blockbuster all day turn into
competitor to Netflix I tried the guy
who owned it it's up not far from here
Pier One wasn't failing as much it was
only failing because covid
shut all the stores down
and when you have 1200 stores and let's
say your average lease just pick a
number is a hundred grand a year
but you can't open the store and make
one penny of Revenue
do the math yeah but weren't they
getting also coveted stimulus checks and
you'd be able to apply for plenty of
loans no not enough not that covid large
Footprints of retail stores locked in at
pre-covered leases so Pier One was a
good business that was temporarily put
out of business my understanding though
is that the revenue was declining and
that they were losing market share to to
online I could be yeah you've made I
mean it was doing 1.7 billion of Revenue
and I bought it for 31 million time will
tell if it's look man you you you you
make bets and I'm not an omnipotent
person but you make your bets and you
live with them and I think buying
distress assets it works in real estate
I know you do a lot of stuff with real
estate it's my philosophy on real estate
like Grant Cardone buys stuff or at any
time of the market right he's been
buying multi-family at arguably
pretty high valuations which is working
for him but I like to buy low maybe it's
because I'm a College Dropout I have a
simple investing formula Buy Low it's
the ultimate margin of safety and I
think a lot of people in the last five
years I was looking at you know Redfin
like Open Door all these open doors just
looking at the news Open Door 1500 homes
they bought in January this year now
they're dumping all of them yeah it's a
terrible business for a hundred thousand
less than they paid that's a hundred and
fifty million Zillow tried to copy it
but I want to come and buy that block of
homes it could be BlackRock who's gonna
buy them some big institutions gonna
offer them one flat rate buy them all
but I've out I've outbid institutions
man buying Pier One Big I was up against
a big private Equity Firm called
Sycamore these are the guys that bid on
Victoria C these are multi-billion
dollars you can win you can win against
these guys and how much did you pay I
paid 31 million a public auction well
what about Radio Shack how much did you
pay to buy Radio Shack that one's
private is undisclosed but yeah that
that one we own with a billionaire Guy
what's the plan with these to revitalize
and sell yeah now brick and mortar we
want to open the stores back up for two
years you bought them you couldn't open
the stores it was covered restrictions
but we bought a you know now's
opportunity I still believe brick and
mortar if you do the stores of the right
size if they're too big like Bed Bath
and Beyond you saw the news like the CFO
killed himself jumped off of jumped out
of his apartment in New York
those stores are huge they have a
hundred thousand square foot stores it's
gonna fail you have to right size the
business adaption you know how is that
going to compete with Amazon that's now
offering same-day delivery for me it
would be such an inconvenience to go and
so one thing you can take all Our Brands
and put them on Amazon so if you can't
beat them join them that's number one
number two
there's some things people still like
going into stores for example even with
Pier One now we used to have a huge
fragrance business Pier One was like the
number three fragrance candles all this
stuff 250 million a year it was doing in
its stores we switch everything to
online guess what we found out women
like to come in and smell the candles so
it's a tougher bit like Amazon you can
beat Amazon for that think about it in
you can't try new stuff I guess you
could order 20 new candles and smell
them and send all the ones back but
people are still going to stores the
full demise of retail I don't think will
happen I just think
it's a shift okay now bodybuilding.com
was something that was surprising to me
because I would shop at bodybuilding.com
a lot yeah I didn't even realize that
was being sold yeah it was off Market
deals how did that come so it was I have
like I keep my feelers out with all the
investment bankers business brokers and
stuff like that that one came up is a
huge business one of the original
supplement like before Amazon you know
but it's been on the decline and I think
it's like the Charles Darwin said it's
not the strongest or the smartest who
survive it's the most adaptable so I
think if you don't adapt all these
businesses are going to disappear
including Apple
have you like iMessage sucks do you use
iMessage yeah I do let's have so much
better what's up you have good voice
memos it's easy to delete stuff you can
have disappearing messages like iMessage
like WhatsApp shot up messages copy of
course but how many years like they
haven't innovated at all I'll get i'll
make a prediction sure there's a serious
chance your grandchildren won't know who
apple is look at Facebook I've been
saying that I'm like Facebook did not
adapt and Tick Tock ate their lunch in
three years really been three years
maybe two
and um you know they got all into the
metaverse and I'm going uh this is a
niche product what do you think of the
metaverse it's a niche product first off
everything's the metaverse already you
to if you define metaverse as a as a you
know digital illusion then that's what
like YouTube is man I mean look people
are gonna watch this thing we're not
really there they're gonna be watching
it while they're sitting laying down but
couldn't we improve this by putting on
VR goggles and it's like someone could
sit right there in that chair that would
be kind of cool you could look around
see all of us at the same time I would
love to do that I think and it would
almost be like you're watching in person
but that's okay but let me just throw
this out
do you think a lot of people woke up
today and they're like you know what's
missing in my life no my goggles to
watch
it what the thing is looking around but
nobody but nobody would think that's
something they need until they have it
like no one would think they need an
iPhone and like uh why would I need to
browse the internet while I'm well I'm
out I'll get back and check my voicemail
it's like when it's there though for
like a you know a premium viewing
experience but at the same time I like
just on my phone going out in the
backyard yeah you know what a lot of
people just agree listen too but this
was a great quote it was Henry and this
got me thinking Henry Ford said if I ask
the customers what they wanted they
would say a faster horse yes and that
got me thinking that people don't know
what they want and you have to provide
it to them I think VR for like porn
might be big I think well that's what
I'm going I don't know how many goggles
I'm doing like yo what's missing in my
life I'm not looking around at the
lighting system well my my understanding
is that is that porn very much paves
away for a lot of these in terms of like
video but the one word feels like yeah
real thing that's when porn will be big
you know what's interesting remember
Clubhouse yes I do so it was like a one
hit wonder it popped in I did this first
person to do
I think I had the biggest room
eventually Elon made the biggest a
couple weeks later but I had like 2 000
people and I go I'm just gonna talk by
myself no interviews I didn't let
anybody else on nobody and I talked and
it went for seven hours and held it was
insane I started like three and I ended
at ten speaking of failing businesses
what's going on with Clubhouse I feel
like no one is using it anymore yeah to
me I have a simple diagnosis that went
wrong
somebody this is a hypothesis but I
think I'm right Somebody went in there I
don't know if somebody was jealous of
people who had big rooms they killed big
rooms they changed the algorithm
somebody made the decisions better to
have 10 000 rooms of 10 people then you
know a hundred huge rooms which I think
is so wrong if you look at the whole
Pareto Principle is what drives social
media it's like 20 of the influencers
get all the views on anything insta Tick
Tock so that's like saying I don't want
you know Kim Kardashian to have 300
million followers I want her to have I
want to have a whole bunch of people who
have 300 000 followers it's a big
psychological psychology mistake that's
why I said if you can people ask me what
do you read a lot I'm like I read
psychology more than anything because
psychology really health wealth love
happiness to be healthy you have to
master your own psychology to like eat
right and go to the gym it's like
self-discipline right wealth
all the money in the world is in other
people's hands so if you don't
understand those people and connect with
them at a deep level they're not going
to give you any money there'll be no
free trade
Love is All a social game friends family
romance and then lastly happiness is
literally almost
how people you know perceive the purpose
of psychology so to me
face Clubhouse they didn't understand
they understood psychology at the
beginning yeah make it free all right
like make it you have to have an invite
code it was a very San Francisco thing I
was like oh and they only gave like
these Keys remember Google Plus did that
and I was like oh man does anybody have
an invite code to Google Plus it was
dead in like a month Facebook did that
at the beginning you had to have a
college address yeah and every dude
wanted it because there was like edu
yeah there was like pretty women on
there so everybody was like ah trying to
get an edu address so they could talk to
all the like 22 year olds what do you
think of Elon Musk charging eight
dollars a month for verification
um I'm just gonna do a good job with
Twitter I would not bet against Elon
Musk he seems to be a prolific success
machine
whether his but he has experiments that
fail I just read this book called
the new book on Elon Musk there's a new
book on Elon Musk I finished it on the
flight here from Europe and he's tried
lots of stuff that's failed this Eight
dollar one the good news if you're a
Elon Musk fan is he's begun the
iteration process and he'll just keep
going until he finds something he's good
enough he'll shut it off if it doesn't
work I'm not sure that's your salvation
eight bucks for it I'm not sure why it's
eight bucks for a blue verification he
wanted to charge 15 and someone
commented underneath that maybe he's 20.
it's 15 or 20. someone commented
underneath I forget who the guy was I'd
know his name if you say it and he said
that's too expensive I wouldn't pay that
and then Elon Musk replies back
immediately after okay fine it's eight
dollars yes that was eight dollars then
and that's how he came up with the
number yeah he came up it's a
spitballing back and forth that's how he
got in all that trouble with the SEC he
said he said uh funding secured 420 and
he came up with that because he thought
his girlfriend Grimes would think
because 420 yeah you know April 20th
weed day yeah and the SEC was like and
he admitted to the SEC like that's
probably not a good way to price the
stock based off weed but you say you
know but that's again we're here talking
about how he came up with eight dollars
that he's a puppet master of people he's
a puppet master and and probably the
best who ever maybe the best
entrepreneur ever lived he's obviously a
great innovator and scientist at some
level but not as good there's been
plenty of those
you know yeah now how do you find the
balance though between being at that
right point where people are talking
about you enough but not going to such
an extreme where it's maybe like a Kanye
West where almost Burning Bridges you
remember you ever seen tropical Tropic
Thunder yeah it's like Robert Downey Jr
it's one of the funniest comedy and he's
like you went full [ __ ] never go full
[ __ ] like Kanye may have gone full
[ __ ] like you can take stuff a little
bit to
too far by the way that's me quoting a
movie I know it's not politically
correct but if you've seen the movie
it's like you know Kanye attacked Jewish
people he had have you ever been to LA
or New York it's like that's a powerful
group of people yes who and you know
it's like do you wanna
pick your battles man and um
so
yeah he I think there you go there's
this concept
in the good life that you were talking
about Socrates
Socrates said like to be angry is easy
but to be angry at the right person at
the right time for the right reason for
the right duration with the right
intensity that's hard and so to air to
Socrates is really Aristotle but
to live the good life everything's in
proportion so it's like how
controversial do you want to be if
you're not controversial enough
you're lost in the sea of noise of
social media
but how many people have been kicked off
all the big platforms recently for being
too extreme and then you lose your voice
look at the dance you watch if you watch
the Google searches on big people who
have been de-platformed it goes down
when you get de-platformed so the
question you know the ideal is take it
right up to the nth degree but not so
much that other humans retaliate and you
have to realize the human species right
now is extremely divided because
everybody has a voice so like America is
insanely politically divided there's not
much of a middle there's a middle but
you don't meet that many people are like
ah Donald Trump no opinion on them like
that's or even Joe Biden it's very
extreme present I'm not sure what's
wrong with America that we have such
it's like either you have like social
media is causing a lot of that it's
definitely the media no yeah it's like
social media though because now now they
have now they're able to show you both
extremes of what gets views right yeah
yeah for sure there's no doubt that
social media is feeding the fire but the
fire was already there in the sense that
you can go back 500 years ago extreme
news made the news like people were
talking about Catherine the Great you
know in the 1500s or or the 1600s I say
so like I think that um
you have to be careful
a guy that I know one of the smartest
guys I know in finance he said listen Ty
I've watched he he's corporate takeover
guys like complicated guy like Carl icon
type person and he's like I've watched
it a million times when people succeed
they get this like Emperor syndrome like
I can never fail and they push the
boundaries until they fall off the cliff
and so you have to always stay humble to
go yeah I'm not sure you should always
say everything you think and now some
people would say no I like that Kanye's
so authentic or Trump so authentic but
there's diminishing returns on being
telling everything like if I walk in a
room and I think
that person's ugly I don't have to go up
and be like I'm a very I just say what I
think like you're horribly you know
disgusting to me like some things you
you have to shut up and so everybody
wants to take it to the nth degree but
but you see there with Kanye it's like
do you want to lose your Empire and I'll
tell you this Kanye has a chance he's a
sharp enough again kind of a social you
know Puppet Master psychology he may
make it back he's a I wouldn't bet
against Kanye fully but is it the
world's greatest chess move to lose your
whole Yeezy Empire like it's a tough
chess move he may be playing such a
complex game that I'm not smart enough
to understand I don't know if he knows
what he's doing but he'll maybe figure
out a way yeah I don't know he's an
Adaptive machine man the thing about
Kanye though for his defense is if you
read the comments he hasn't he has built
a much bigger fan base than I've ever
seen
people you know America roots for the
damn Underdog America hates it's just a
very David and Goliath part of America
so like when Trump was I remember the
day of Trump's the election where they
were tallying the votes the New York
Post or New York Times or whatever had
90 chance that Hillary Clinton won would
win and I remember going watching the
day and it like spun all the way around
and I was thinking America likes an
underdog never if I was Hillary Clinton
I'd be like don't jinx me like that
don't be putting that I'm a clear winner
because Americans are the kind of people
culturally like I think the media is
picking on Trump too much I don't even
like Trump but this damn media like I
see that sometimes I look at Twitter I'm
like this thing is too they are pushing
up stuff that's so ideologically slanted
that it pisses me off
and so I I think that Kanye
for the good news and Trump they built
this massive following just by
saying what everybody else was thinking
it's a powerful thing to say what other
people think yeah I think Tate as well
uh between social media and him and
trying to silence an opinion yes now all
of a sudden people will listen to that
opinion more because they're like what
silenced what's what's so bad about this
let me listen to this you know who
threads the needle well Ben Shapiro and
that
Ben Shapiro doesn't get D platform right
I think his app has a million people
paying 10 bucks a month in the first
three months oh for sure serious that's
lowball I think they publish that he
he's he's making it 10 to 20 million a
month with his own I had no idea dude
that premium because of the world
they're like family values right so if
you're like a more religious person and
the media is pushing up such a kind of
left
it you're the whole silent majority is
insane but I'm just saying Ben Shapiro
he pushes it but doesn't get himself
deeply he's he's very strategic he
doesn't quite say enough that they can
boot him off
you know whereas Trump pushes it harder
I would say Elon you know I'd say Ben
Shapiro is going to be a billionaire a
multi-billionaire he might end up being
richer than Trump
I mean Shapiro's like 35 or something so
that's why I say you have to realize in
life that everything that's out of
proportion to me ends up being
problematic so it's like if you work out
like there's a time in my life where I
didn't work out at all just focus on
making money it's problematic you you
you you create maybe a vacuum you'll
never be able to fill again you know I
see it's for example A lot of people are
like ah
you know [ __ ] everything I'm just gonna
make money I'm like avoid that but on
the flip side I know other people that
are like money doesn't matter but it
does how did you find that balance sure
I don't think I have but I have well in
hindsight yeah I have pinpointed when I
had it
and like so you have to sometimes go
past it sure I know the year like 2013
was a good year
that was a year in my life I think maybe
I achieved like the full almost the
Pinnacle of stuff and that was right
before your ad right that was before it
that was a couple that was a year or two
I remember wait I'll tell you what when
you wake up super happy you've hit it's
called the the air the Socrates word is
called euda monia which means like the
beautiful life
and if you think about what beauty is
like when you say somebody's beautiful
or architect or you know a landscape
it's it's that ratio like the human they
call it the golden you know the the
golden ratio is like 0.61 hip to waist
ratio shoulder to waste like humans look
at patterns when we say you know this
woman is super beautiful it's like
you're looking at subconsciously you're
looking at ratios so I think a way you
if you find yourself and this is a
problem on social media you're talking
about misdiagnosing health like
everybody is either saying denying
depression anxiety or saying that it's
super normal and there's nothing you can
do about it like not really depress some
of depression for sure is genetic your
genetic Baseline Dr Buss always tells me
you know every human's born with like a
genetic Baseline so on a one to ten some
people are like naturally revert to a
four they're kind of melancholy people
you know and some people are like a nine
they've done studies on people who have
a car accident and they're paralyzed
okay
and you know in three months you revert
to whatever happiness level you were
before paralyzed so like for three
months you're like super unhappy but in
general people who were depressed before
become depressed and people are kind of
cheery become cheery so if there's a
genetic Baseline but there's also an
environmental part that is a signal like
pain is a signal to change so I think
you look at the point in your life where
you woke up the most at peace that's
probably when you're getting close to
that ratio of the four pillars of the
good life health wealth love happiness
because if you're making a hell of a lot
of money but you're you know your your
social life sucks you'll wake up a
little bit lonely so that's what I think
all people should try to optimize for
that where do you fall on the scale what
do you think you could optimize optimize
um
probably
as I've been the last three years I've
been so focused my social life has not
been as good as it used to be I'm just
like busy yeah I miss like
2009 to like 2019 like my social life
was like nine out of ten you know of
what I want maybe somebody else but like
in my scale of like it was like a night
like every day I was I was like my best
friends were in business with me my
family so I'd see them every night I was
going out with friends it was very like
European life like Europeans are like ah
Americans work too hard they used to
call America the merchant class they're
like ah they just care about money and
there's some truth like I live in
Scandinavia it's Scandinavians have the
best life that is a place that has good
ratios so when you look back on this
time period in your life where you felt
like you were pretty at balance can you
walk us through maybe like an average
day or explain where you were at in each
of those four categories yeah I think
like the day if I could build in my past
the best average day or the best day
what that daily routine looked like I
would be like I think it's simple I
think you should wake up and exercise
it's like just do them in order health
wealth love happiness so like Health
Arnold Schwarzenegger I once I was at
his house and I was like can I interview
in his kitchen he smokes cigars in his
kitchen pretty funny sitting here
smoking a cigars like right in the
kitchen I'm like okay and I and I and I
said what's your daily routine he's like
I wake up at four
four to five I feed my brain get my
brain health so he reads for an hour
he's like five I get on my bicycle and I
write to Gold's Gym
and I work out and I come back or at
seven I eat breakfast and then eight I
start working I was thinking that's a
hard schedule to beat I don't think you
have to wake up at four I've tried the
thing where you wake up crazy early
I think it's genetic I think some people
are more night owls because I I did
experiment for like a year where I woke
up at three I would wake up at 3 30 and
I wanted everybody in the office my
leaders there at four and we do a leader
meeting my God
how is that did you notice any
difference in productivity no probably
worse really that's what now when I was
on how long did you do that for until
everybody like burnt out all the leaders
are like I'm not gonna do this man
because they were having to like drive
it get up at 2 45 and stuff so but but
the general gist is wake up what I try
to do is like wake up on my best days
wake up
I read right away I I think iBooks is an
under the most underrated app in the
world is iBooks on my on my phone I've
got so many good books it's literally
insane so here's my library you can just
see like and I have audiobooks oh you do
audiobooks okay but like when I wake up
if I just here's this new book on Elon
Musk power play great book here's Miss
Jane Pittman story of you know she was
reading on it Carnegie yeah and uh that
was the Gospel of wealth this is the
autobiography of Charles Darwin I think
the best thing to read is textbooks and
autobiographies or biographies I've got
ishy that was the last Native American
in America
Sun Tzu's The Art of War this is a book
by a rock star this is the book I read
this Michael Gross is the story of like
supermodels I I own I'm the second
largest owner of wilhemina models which
is the biggest model com I read
contagious which is a psychology book do
you have like a list like where you log
all the books that you're reading yeah
Tai lopez.com books I have this free
free one I'm not selling anything there
but I've got 659 books
I've read only 176 so I just like when
I'm on a flight so I think the best
thing is what Arnold said wake up read
or audio books just a little bit then
some form of low intensity cardio he
does a bicycle takes him about 30
minutes to get to Jim I walk so like
when I'm in Puerto Rico my gym is
exactly about a mile and a half I walk
there low intensity walk back you're
basically I try to get to 20 000 steps a
day there's some new science that you
really should try men were built to walk
about 22 000 steps which is 10 miles and
if you look at like hunter gatherers
there's a new book called exercise by
this Daniel Lieberman who's a
paleoanthropologist he studies are your
bone structure he's at Harvard and he's
like he studied women on average
walkabouts a little bit less seven miles
a day so
little reading for the brain health of
the brain
even as just a page like it cleanses the
mind it's like I always said like
especially if you read somebody you
brought up Socrates read something
classic it's almost like mental hijus
like soap you get to wash off all the
tick tock like all the stupid stuff it's
like you read like Civilization is
discontent so it may be the most
compact book of value in the last
thousand years that's like Sigmund Freud
there's one the second chapter I
probably read it 300 times so maybe read
that then walk then hit the gym so
you've done health
then go make money I think in an Ideal
World I think the four hour work week is
too weirdly low like working four hours
a week I think you'll lose meaning
humans built to work a little bit you
know so I think like four hours a day is
a better goal so four or five hours a
day of work and then so it's health
wealth so now you've done you knocked
the health out you knock the wealth out
now love friends family romance like
evenings when I was at my favorite time
of my life evenings was like come about
six or seven o'clock
it's like going out with friends dinner
Comedy Club movie restaurant and just
like for a long time like three four
hours and I would incorporate my dating
life like I rarely would go on
one-on-one dates Adrian how often would
I do one-on-one dates like never
especially First Dates I'm like ah never
you get stuck with somebody it's like oh
man I'd be like hey I'm out with like 15
people come meet me so much better I met
this Brazilian girl one time
right when she got out of the car I was
like this is not my type but my friend
Jeremy was there and I was like you're
gonna beat my friend so you can even be
like yeah he can pass pass somebody on
it's not a good day it worked out great
they stayed together for five years you
know what's funny they never were not
together for five straight years really
every day what happened what happened
after that for five years so a long time
she got super jealous this is a dope
joke he's like I think she's too jealous
I was like why do you think that because
he likes gen like guys say they don't
like when a woman does this but I'm like
but you stayed with her for five years
she was angry that he set the navigation
voice to a sexy girl's voice and she
brought it up as a big thing as like I
feel like am I not enough for you oh no
Rio I I can't make this up she's like do
you think she's might be a little too
extreme I'm like yes I'm like the fact
you have to ask me if that's too extreme
I'm worried about your mental health but
so they eventually broke up and he's
married now but be sure to use Samuel
Jackson's voice that's always my
favorite that's your navigation voice
I loved it so you got help wealth love
then you get home and you go to bed
happy because happy I always say so in
the four pillars I say
health is the necessity of the good life
okay
health is wealth is the indispensable of
the good life
like even if you don't like money you're
gonna have to have it because you don't
make your own clothing or build your own
home or you know mind your own coal to
heat the house love is the purpose of
life even if you're not a romantic
person and you talk to doctor of us he's
like everything's mating like humans are
built around mating right Evolution love
and then happiness is the culmination
of the good life if you've done the
first three pillars it's it's what
Michael Jordan says he goes you don't
strive for greatness you do all the
right things and then it's bestowed upon
you that's how he looked at winning six
rings as an NBA basketball champion so
to me it's like the last pillar you
cannot Chase it's like a cat if you want
to pet a cat it doesn't want you to pet
it but when you do everything else right
it comes up to you and so that so you've
got the necessity you've got the
indispensable you've got the purpose and
then lastly you'll go to bed and wake up
happy that's the culmination of this
first three being perfectly aligned but
you gotta align them you can't do like I
know people I have friends at work
you know 16 hours on making money or 15
hours and then they go to the gym for 20
minutes I'm like the ratio's off it's
not gonna work and actually there's good
science even that the US government put
something out and said if you sit eight
hours a day
a one hour on the treadmill basically
does nothing it does not offset it so
even like the cheesy U.S government kind
of yeah what are you supposed to do if
you work eight hours a day at a cubicle
or at a computer go to the gym for like
five hours so how do you treadmill
treadmill this is the most practical
investment a person can make of twelve
hundred dollars dude like I don't sit I
this right here I bet you I bet you I
sit
less than 20 minutes a day on average
sitting is the destruction of the human
body I some I've actually heard that a
lot it is sitting is it's horrible it's
way better to go I lay on a couch all
the way like lay and read or I go back
in my bed and lay down humans are not
you're better off squatting like you see
like old villagers that like squat down
but humans sitting I I've so you're
saying laying down is better than
sitting and it basically
anything go to your job and be like yo
I'm gonna pay sir like I was on this
airplane back from Europe it was 10
hours to get here London to Vegas and
um I went you know there's that little
area even though I had a lie flat you
know but I they have that little area
where you can have snacks and the I
don't know if the stewardess thought I
was a terrorist or something I was gonna
try to like open she kept checking on me
like every 20 minutes she's like are you
okay do you want to go sit down I'm like
no I don't want to [ __ ] sit so I got
in like 5 000 steps by walking you look
at dudes like my dad was in prison
people in a little prison cell keep
themselves you see those dudes all
ripped up they they walk around for like
six hours a day in a little cell so
walking is important walk man walk and
lift it I I I've worked on this thing
called the million dollar body so it's
going to come out as a book and an
e-book and a course cheap I'm gonna
charge like a dollar but
um so in 2015 my health was like going
down I looked at myself I'm like what
the [ __ ] I lost muscle mass I was just
like so focused on this business so
I said I'm gonna spend a million dollars
over five years 200 000 approximately a
year I probably spent a million and a
half but let's say a million as I'm
gonna try everything every supplement
trt I'm gonna try you know all the
hydrotherapy I'm gonna try every diet
veganism keto this that that I'm gonna
do heavyweight CrossFit Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu more I did everything and I tested
my the key was get real scientific data
so my nurse that used to come to my
house once a month she's like Ty you're
over she made me sign a waiver she's
like you're not supposed to take this
much blood out of your body I took like
40 vials per time and I did it monthly
for a couple years then and I did a dexa
scan which is like the best muscle mass
accurate better than like water
displacement or anything and so I did
that and so
I really went deep down
the rabbit hole of of health and I and
your blood you the blood tells the truth
you test your blood you know that you're
like sometimes you look healthy people
on steroids can look healthy but like
their bloods all and it's also ratios so
it's like you can have total
testosterone high but if you have too
much estrogen or sex binding globulin or
hormone right it ties up your free test
so this thing about being in Balance you
even find with health but the number one
thing that I just tell people is like
start with walking but then Monday
Wednesday Friday lift heavy weight that
changes your that changes your blood a
lot like improves you better than
anything else you can do and then
Tuesday Thursday Saturday do high
intensity interval training something
like a sport
but you have to spike I had this guy
random guys like a UFC fighter but like
no name he didn't do that well in UFC
remember that Norwegian guy I don't know
if remember we had red in the testing on
all the machines for the UFC he came as
the fittest person who's ever been
through the UFC lab so I asked him I was
like bro what's your trick he's like
three times a week spiked the heart like
super high like 20 times so you I you
can get this cheap thing you put under
on your chest if you work out according
to heartbeat it's much better because
when you're out of shape you'll over
train yourself and kind of hurt yourself
at the beginning and when you're in
shape you'll under train so you
basically do heartbeat trying to keep
yourself so Tuesday Thursday Saturday do
that high intensity stuff and then walk
six day and then Sunday do nothing like
I try to get my steps to like 200 steps
I'm like I'm gonna hire somebody to like
wheel me around wow yeah because you if
you do there's good science this new
exercise book by this Lieberman guy also
talks about that you need about one day
per seven days of like insane that's
something I learned from the Amish they
work crazy hard but they stop on Sunday
or else you're basically your
reproductive side like your sex right
your test if you do too much it it you
don't want to mess up your reproductive
side yeah so how much muscle have you
put on lately I put on I definitely I
noticed yeah I've spiked like when I was
on trt you'll go up
and I have kind of naturally my dad was
a pro bodybuilder so my baseline's a
little like seven eight hundred but I've
spiked It trt Go to 3 000. that's a
crazy you get strong boy and I did it
all legally with like doctor stuff a lot
of dudes on social are like on they're
on trt but they don't want to say I
don't know why people don't want to say
I'm like probably everybody on every
male on Earth will be on trt by like the
end of this and it's becoming a lot more
common [ __ ] just like the only reason I
don't like trt is if you want to have
kids your sperm count goes like [ __ ]
zero which if you don't want to have
kids better in birth control is [ __ ]
trts like you get all jacked up you get
strong I could bench like I mean I was
repping like 3 15. but isn't it true
that you have to stay on it then for the
rest of your life yeah I mean it's it's
a that's why I don't do it I haven't
done it for years you can gain muscle
without it you're just not gonna look
like Superman so I don't think you
should do it I is my basic thing but
what I do think you should do test the
blood and take the specific things with
now the thing about supplements I found
where everybody goes wrong they take
years to kick in but they eventually
kick in so if you do like your
supplements for like two months this is
zero benefit that [ __ ] and I've learned
that I have 1300 Acres of Farmland
humans are very much I'm very much
focused on the soil like fertile soil is
like the basis of a civilization and the
soil is the same way when your soil is
out of balance doesn't have calcium
phosphorus it takes you like two years
to really revive the soil there's a slow
metabolism of the soil and our body is
built to not make quick changes so like
you might be low on magnesium so I I got
Ben Greenfield he's a guy who's been on
like Joe Rogan three times I I paid him
I don't know how much 25 000 to build
like a supplement program just for me
but if you if you can't do that I mean
there's some simple stuff eat organ
Meats like the liver King guy yeah we
had him on the podcast yeah you had him
yeah so like I that's but I will tell
you the problem with that is you can
actually my bees are too high you're
what so your B vitamins you get a lot of
B's from these things like you can also
poison yourself on liver
you you have to be careful with that
stuff that's why I said the problem is
social media
everything extreme goes viral which then
we see on our feed which we then believe
is gospel because it's like it's
basically brainwashing it's subliminal
messaging that brainwashes you but the
truth is there's always some true so
every extreme person you can name even
extreme feminists there's some truth to
what they say like men are definitely
Killers compared to women you know
culture feminine feminists are like if
there was less men there'd be less crime
I'm like that's definitely true
I if you go on Wikipedia out of a
thousand serial killers count them for
yourself there's two
serial killer women and 998 men the last
time I did account so
there is truth in every extreme the
problem is the extreme
becomes like a Frankenstein monster and
turns the beauty of the idea ugly and so
that's what I'm saying like liver for
example on a practical thing and all the
organ Meats like you can take that [ __ ]
too extreme you can kill yourself for
sure or poison yourself slowly so that's
why I said the blood doesn't lie man
yeah test your but everybody should test
their blood like at least twice a year
and you go to the doctor and just say I
want all the extra stuff please give me
the extra stuff because doctors now on
insurance they get they test for the
minimum yes so this is something I'm
actually doing because it's been forever
since I did a checkup yeah I'm just
doing just a just a general thing but
they wanted to test for blood and it was
only like four things on them no get mad
at them I go in there with a piece of
paper and I'm like I want this and
they're like we're not gonna do it I'm
like do this yeah they added it all in
and just you just tell them what you
want to test for and they'll just type
it in and uh yeah some of the big Labs
like Quest Labs or Lab Core yeah you can
now order online and you just add
everything and when the nurse comes be
like is there any make sure you for
example a big one people don't
vitamin D this is a game changer so and
yes you could take supplements but when
I lived in Puerto Rico I got you get
healthy there's the reason Puerto Rico
became famous is uh you remember Ponce
de Leon in history he's trying to find
the Fountain of Youth there was a famous
guy in the 1600s and he went to Florida
and didn't find I could have told him
Florida ain't the Fountain of Youth it's
like everything Florida wants to kill
you crocodiles and steak but he ended up
in Puerto Rico because the governor and
he died there he lived the rest of his
life because there was the most Indians
living into their hundreds and part of
it is there's always vitamin D Vegas
where you are is good for vitamin D so
there's an app I am not affiliated with
like just Sun yes there's this app
called D Minor right here okay a NASA
scientist made it I'm not affiliated I
don't make it I think it costs five
bucks a year or something dude it's the
best but not damn thing now Luana knows
something scary
I actually said it wrong you can't get
vitamin D in Vegas
for another hundred days because the
sun's too low in the sky Yeah so
basically you that's why you that's why
native groups like migrated like the
Native Americans like they would go
south
you're healthier it's a big thing but
you can take vitamin D but it's never as
good when you take it now how do you
balance that with with skin cancer
so this vitamin here's the crazy thing
when you're in good Sun you need like in
Puerto Rico I'd get eight minutes of it
and this thing tells you exactly when
you get too much so if for all you are
like I know you like scientific apps
this dime D Minor I want to buy this app
from the dude because I don't think he's
updated it and since he built it but it
gives you your score oh my gosh for
seven like I've been it look I've been
in Sweden no vitamin D yeah past seven
days is 40. I needed 77 000 units I've
only gotten 40 000 units so I know I
gotta up my supplements vitamin D is a
huge one in fact a lot of the coveted
people that were anti-vaccine they were
like you can just take vitamin D [ __ ] I
can believe it well my so you test your
vitamin D make sure they don't add that
it's a crime
makes you want to be on the upper range
of the recommended right to the top I'm
definitely not I'll tell you that I
don't know he's a vampire I don't go
outside yeah dude I'll tell you what
will change your life
do more business on the phone go in your
backyard Pace back and forth
get this I use an aura ring yeah but
what it'll tell you
it tells you if your sleep sucks
sleep I would say I always say the most
what I learned from this million dollar
body I can sum up in like nine the nine
tenets of health and I would say number
one is sleep
I'm honestly number two is walking
I believe that I believe that we sleep
yeah I believe that too
um I know we gotta wrap this up yeah
guys this is just uh I just have two
things uh one uh you know thanks to our
sponsor Lexar that's all I have to say
oh sorry my sponsor Lexar so what's
Lexar oh Ty I'm so glad that you asked
this Lexar they actually make SD cards
you know memory storage ssds uh you know
if you give me some info I'll have them
send you some send me some lexars I'm
definitely gonna send you some lexares
yeah for 100 all right guys well with
that said thank you so much go to
toddlupas.com books that's my free
contribution to the World free books yo
it just tells you what books to buy you
recommend three books three of them
books life-changing books you've read
for business Gary Keller the one thing
you know him from real estate on how to
focus
um on psychology
there I'll give you four for the four
pillars of Good Life so for business
Gary killer one thing is a great one or
health the story of the human body by
this guy Lieberman it's a little more
advanced book but it's like a badass but
for health
or
love and friendship and romance and all
that Dr David Buss textbook called
evolutionary psychology it's a textbook
but it reads like a book it's
fascinating and then for happiness read
civilization and it's discontents by
Sigmund Freud it is
maybe the greatest three pages I've ever
read the second chapter is all you need
to read
and it's on
what it's what's the purpose of life
it's the greatest three pages I think if
you're a little more logical it's not a
super woo-woo one so if you're more into
the woo-woo you won't like that but
that's my four thank you thanks really
appreciate it thank you so much amazing
man I hope this is okay you enjoyed this
I could go for another hour yeah we get
another podcast right now but man if it
weren't for that we'd be going no that's
good well we'll have to do it again I'll
have to have you all on my podcast yeah
I have the ice
thank you guys for watching make sure to
get your free stock Down Below in the
description
thank you Ty thank you
I love that so that was okay